the next three hours is your chance to
participate in a discussion with one of
today's leading political satirists
join us as book tv's in depth welcomes
pj o'rourke author of several
best-selling books including parliament
of [ __ ] and give war a chance
his latest is on the wealth of nations
[Music]
p.j o'rourke what do you write about
i write about things i don't understand
i write about things that i'm ignorant
about
now there are a lot of writers out there
who write about things that they do
understand whether it's suburbia or
franco-prussian war or
the ins and outs of lobbying in in
washington
but what's always interested me what
makes me interested as a reporter
is that i don't understand a lot of
things
maybe i don't understand anything so
they don't understand most things so i
go out and i try and find out about them
and that's what i write about how many
countries have you visited
you know i did sit down and count once
it was 70 something i i
have a bunch
and
what are some of the more hell holish
places that you've been oh nothing tops
mogadishu mogadishu is the winner
really hold the calls
we have a champion
i was there i was there when president
bush first president bush visited
after he lost the election
but before he was out of office so it
was christmas time i spent christmas in
new year's
1992 at mogadishu i was working for abc
radio
and we had
we could not step outside the compound
without armed guards we had 40 some
armed guards in our compound we could
not set foot outside that compound
without those armed guards and
we were a little worried about setting
foot inside the compound too because we
had these armed guards
and we never did figure out whether they
were fully trustworthy or not and
actually the answer was no they would
chew cot
which is a mild narcotic
i had course child of the 60s i had to
try it myself
it's kind of like having four or five
cups of coffee on an empty stomach
not really much of a drug
but
it worked for them they'd start chewing
cotton about 10 in the morning and it
would take until about three in the
afternoon to kick in
and then they'd start screaming at each
other and discharging their firearms in
the air and maybe sometimes at each
other and we called it the cot hour
and that's when we
were prisoners within the compound that
we were prisoners within i mean that's
when we locked the doors for against our
own armed guards never mind what was
outside the walls
in one of your books you write about
your experience in mogadishu and you
talk about the fact that in the
marketplace there there were there was
rice for sale it was rice that was
donated
yes
kind of say no more about your food
donations uh of course i guess it was
getting to people which is better than
some of the food donations to africa you
know there are famous cases uh during
the famine in ethiopia when the
communists were still in charge were
where the rice never got off the docks
where it rotted on the docks so at least
in mogadishu it was getting out to the
customers albeit not in the way that the
donors had expected or hoped you say you
write about things you don't understand
your most recent book pj o'rourke on the
wealth of nations this is about adam
smith
yeah and i don't understand big time
well i understand now a little better
than i did before i read all 900 pages
of the wealth of nations but i wouldn't
want to pass myself off as an expert but
i think that the reader will get
something out of this i hope the rio
gets something out of this because they
can come
i always figure i'm an average guy
i'm an average intellect an average
capacity for understanding you know
those uh sudoku puzzles
you know that get harder as the week
goes by
i'm good through wednesday
thursday friday saturday forget about it
so
the reader can kind of come with me
up to the point where i run out of steam
will probably be about the same point
that the average reader will run out of
steam and i say look here's some
brilliant brilliant stuff and let's get
as much out of it as we can
and
you tell me when you're exhausted and
i'll tell you when i'm exhausted and
then we'll quit and
go read some elmore leonard who is adam
smith
who was adam smith adam smith was
the first guy to really understand
economics as we presently understand the
term
he was the person who realized that
economics was
not
a metaphysical thing that it was not a
mysterious thing that it was simply the
way that we make our living
and he was the first person to
understand that the way that we make our
living is dependent upon just three
prerogatives three individual freedoms
one is the freedom to pursue
self-interest
the other is division of labor
essentially the freedom to choose our
jobs
and the third is trade
and those are the three legs of the
stool all of economics
stands upon that stool
knock any of the legs out from under the
stool and you get communist romania
invisible hand appears on page 485
of wealth of nations
um
why do people know that about adam smith
ah you see
adam smith of course is misunderstood
aren't we all misunderstood
misunderstanding i mean without
misunderstanding what would we
journalists do for a living
invisible hand a couple things that
people picked up from adam smith and as
usual
with a deep thinker
they didn't pick up the right things
invisible hand is usually used to mean
the way that
capitalist system
naturally promotes everybody's welfare
and naturally grows richer it's not at
all what adam smith meant by invisible
hand
by invisible hand what adam smith was
talking about is the is is the way
things
work
when we don't perceive
how they work
in other words
when i pursue my self-interest and you
pursue your self-interest we actually
end up cooperating with each other
because you will because of division of
labor you do something i do something
else
we need to trade those two things we
mutually benefit from this trade this is
a kind of invisible hand
it's an invisible hand because we
haven't intended to do this we haven't
intended to make this cooperation
between ourselves adam smith actually
used the invisible hand he used the the
the the the simile uh of an invisible
hand
uh first when he was in an essay when he
in his 20s when he was writing about
physics
and he was saying he was actually it was
kind of a disparaging reference the
invisible hand he said people have
always had an instinctive understanding
of physics certain way fire burns water
quenches
light things rise heavy things fall
so they didn't
he said even the dumbest most primitive
person doesn't think the invisible hand
of jove is involved in making water wet
or fire hot they knew that there were
mechanics involved
he only uses the the the the the the
simile or the metaphor
because he uses it once his assembly
wants us a metaphor let's not get into
that he only uses that again
about twice in fact exactly twice
in the rest of his uh work
it is not a fundamental principle that
his work is based on he uses invisible
hand in an earlier book of his called
the theory of moral sentiments
to show that no matter how greedy rich
people are they can't help but spread
their wealth around because their
stomachs just aren't any bigger than
ours so they may grow a million bushels
of wheat but they can't eat a million
bushels of wheat they've got to somehow
figure a way to get that wheat to
somebody else or do something with it
because they say they may be worse than
we are but their stomachs are not bigger
they can wear more expensive clothes
than we can but they can't wear more
clothes than we can or not many more
they'd fall over be unable to move
so therefore the product
that
rich people produce
has to be shared not because they want
it to be shared they're very greedy but
because this is the nature of things he
uses the invisible hand there
and he uses it once again in in in the
wealth of nations in a funny little
passage about how uh
about protecting domestic industry where
it so happens that by adam smith's own
reasoning on free trade he is in this
one little individual passage wrong just
plain wrong i mean he was a genius but
he wasn't such a genius that he couldn't
occasionally be wrong
are you a free market capitalist and is
at was adam smith a free market
capitalist let us make a distinction
between free market and capitalist
um
capitalist is a weird term uh in fact i
i in fact i think it's probably a term
we could just do away with
a capitalist is actually a marxist term
it's it's an idea
that uh
that the accumulation of excess labor
and wealth
is necessary to
fuel a modern economy
that you have to have capital to fuel a
modern economy
and in a limited sense it's true
but you also have to have a lot of other
things notably innovation
expansion of markets
all sorts of stuff besides capital if
you just go around providing people with
capital you're essentially giving money
to bombs
you could say a guy who's standing on a
corner trying to
get a couple bucks together so he can
buy a bottle of musketeer you could say
he lacked capital
and you could give him that capital and
what he's going to do with it is by the
musketeer you know and then fall down
later
let's
forget about capital for a moment and
talk about
free market yes i'm a free market person
and
and adam smith's basic message was free
markets
not free markets because
they lead to us getting rich or him
getting rich
but free markets emphasize the free part
adam smith was a huge moral and
practical proponent of freedom
what he was really talking about
was freedom
the freedom
to do the job that we want
the freedom to get the fruits of our own
labor the freedom to exchange those
fruits of our own labor with other
people under any circumstances that we
feel are fair
it was adam smith who pointed out that
the source of wealth it's not capital
it's it's it's it's freedom
freedom is the source of wealth and
freedom of trade that is to say free
market is is key to that
um you can do more with a free market
than you can with all the capital in the
world you have all the capital in the
world if you don't have freedom to use
that capital it's meaningless or if
you're
just a fool with your capital it's also
meaningless
good afternoon and welcome to in depth
p.j o'rourke is our guest for the next
three hours we're going to put the phone
numbers up on the screen we want to hear
from you you can see the numbers there
202 is the area code for all of them
737-001 for democrats and 737-002 for
republicans and independents 202
202-628-0205 is the number for you to
call if you'd like to email in a
question for pj o'rourke book tv at
cspan.org will begin taking those calls
in just a few minutes
do you consider one second just do you
have a is there a fourth phone number
for completely crazy people well
we'll allow them to call in on any line
they'd like
yeah because they they do fall into
those three categories but there's
something about economics
that really brings them out of the
woodwork and i'll bet you anything we
get a couple of calls they may get
screened out you know from people who
think that the queen of england controls
all the gold in the world
or that the
fort knox uh you know that there are
martians in fort knox and and so on
we don't screen those calls out so we
we've had those calls on c-span before
i can handle it
t.j o'rourke you consider yourself a
journalist a foreign correspondent a
satirist just a reporter
really just a reporter um
something about journalist
that's a little too elevated it or
it means i keep a journal
which you know sort of makes me think of
of
lonely
divorced people with an interest in
the crafts
and taking
amateur painting
courses on weekends and
and
gardening more than is probably healthy
for them people in other words without
enough to do so let's get rid of
journalists um
satirist
satirist
technically means that you have a moral
point of view it's it's the use of
humor
uh
for moral ends
do you not have a moral point of view
oh
everybody's got a moral point of view
but do
do i deserve to have my moral point of
view be taken seriously no
it's not just not that moral a person
so let's just say reporter you know i
mean
maybe my reporting is a little funnier
than some people's reporting although
well maybe my reporting is a little more
intentionally or at least i mean it to
be intentionally funny there's a lot of
funny reporting out there how many books
have you sold
i don't know i honestly don't know
um
a lot uh uh in that i i think this is
the i think this is the 12th book i've
written it happens to say on the dust
cover that it's it's the
that i that it's the 11th but they're
they're wrong i i did count the other
day
and they've sold pretty well so there
must be a bunch of them out there i see
them in the remainders
uh section in the in the used bookstore
all the time so uh on the other hand i i
i
obviously not enough or
i
live in a bigger house and have an
airplane well you consider yourself a
reporter here's what james fallows had
to say about you in 1991
when pj o'rourke lacks reporting he
falls back on wisecracks and pat
attitudes and when forced to choose
between making a joke and conveying a
less snappy truth he usually goes for
the laugh
well
jim has got me nailed dead to rights
right there and jim if you're listening
when jim lacks reporting he falls back
on
seriousness
jim's very good at being serious
in fact nobody doesn't quite like him
because it's something i think he got in
the carter administration and he hasn't
let loose so there jim
we're even here are some of pj
o'rourke's books here's his most recent
just out on the wealth of nations
here is peace kills
give war a chance is another one
parliament of [ __ ]
the ceo of the sofa where do you come up
with the titles
yeah usually a good title deserves a
book uh i i i i often have the titles
long
before uh
before the the book has occurred to me
peace kills is something that somebody
asked me to put in their book as a you
know i said how would you like this
inscribed and i said
put put put a peace sign
put a cross mark through it
and and and sign it to me peace kills as
a kid in toronto
at a university in toronto
give war a chance with something that
was written over somebody's work station
at an air force base during the first
gulf war
i stole it there
ceo of the sofa was a tribute to
to oliver wendell holmes oliver wendell
holmes senior
who wrote the the autocrat of the
breakfast table and i was thinking what
would the modern equivalent of the
autocratic breakfast table be ceo of the
cell phone the bachelor home companion
is another one
enemies list
we've got age and guile beat youth
innocence and a bad haircut said that
was one i didn't have a title for
obviously
is this picture on the left is that a
real picture of you oh yeah
not a wig not a wig when was it taken
that was um
must i would guess 71
not quite positive what were your
politics in 1971 uh i think that uh a a
martian left
uh w would would be the easiest way to
to sum it up i was a left winger but uh
i didn't make enough sense to actually
be a communist or a trotsky ad or
anything like that and when did the
transformation occur
well it was gradual
yeah i mean it took place over uh in
fact i just wrote about this uh there is
a book coming out um
uh from the um uh
the hoover
uh uh uh institution is is backing this
edited by mary eberstad called
why why i turned right and it's the
story of a bunch of us and why we became
right it actually is a it is a long
story and i won't tell it but i'll give
the short version
um
i was a radical leftist
very much in favor of some sort of
marxist socialist thing in america
i got a job
i got a job paying
150 a week
i was a messenger in new york 150 a week
was a lot of money as far as i was
concerned i was living down the lower
east side
and i was very broke
we got paid every two weeks i was really
looking forward to that 300 bucks
uh and so was my landlord i may say
and and my drug dealer and a number of
other people
and
i got my first paycheck and i netted out
at like 178 or something like that
this is supposed to be 300 bucks
but after federal tax and state tax city
tax social security
health care retirement fund which i
really cared a lot about in those days
and i said wait a minute wait a minute i
have been advocating socialism
marxism you know communism
for years screaming and yelling and
demonstrating the street
and we already have it they just took
half my pay
what's going on here you know i'm not
rockefeller they just took half my pay
you know we have socialism that's when i
started to snap out of it
for a while somebody else who
made a switch in their politics was
christopher hitchens
and yeah now much more recently right
but back in 1993 i believe here's what
he had to say about you
is a guy who gets away in my opinion
with murder i mean he's um he's another
ex-leftist
um 60s radical dropout wrote very
funnily about what it was like being
permanently stoned and bummed out and
paranoid in the 60s then saw the light
put on a collar and tie became a young
republican and has been cashing in this
chip ever since
and has terrific sort of following as a
humorist
um for his books of essays one the first
one quite funny is called republican
party reptile
and the next one was called is called
holidays in hell and more recent one is
called give war a chance
and these sell terribly well among the
young much better than any of my books
ever have and it gets me down so this is
my revenge upon him do you know what i
had yeah i met him sure and he has quite
a good guy to hang out with in a bar and
so forth but i i've reckoned that he was
running on empty with this joke about i
know
i know i've been there i've been in the
radical now i see how wonderful it would
be to be
a completely buttoned up button-down
tory
and the joke basically depends on
on a satire on political correctness you
know
okay so people try not to make jokes
about aids pj will make a joke about
aids
okay it's not funny to laugh at cripples
well i'll laugh about cripples and i
said look
in the words of the
title of the review that's not that's
quite funny but it's not funny enough
christopher christopher chris for
getting away with murder
i i might get away with um
slander
you know verbal assault you know
i don't think i've even ever gotten away
with i'm just a little guy i'm kind of
cowardly i've never even gotten away
with physical assault
and so i think he overstates the case
um
and also of course
i'm long past the point where i can
claim to be a young republican buttoned
down or not
i'm an old republican now unlike most
middle-aged white guys i mean we're all
republicans even if we sometimes call
ourselves something else like democrat
you didn't know you were going to come
over here this afternoon and get
attacked did you
[Laughter]
holidays in hell is another pj o'rourke
book
p.j o'rourke all the trouble in the
world
modern manners an etiquette book for
rude people first book first book when
was this put out uh the original edition
of that was 1983.
eat the rich what was this about now eat
the rich was what got me started on what
wound up being adam smith
which was i was simply puzzled i didn't
understand
why some countries are rich and other
countries are poor
and so i
started poking around going to rich
countries in poor countries and trying
to see if i could figure out
why this country was rich in other
countries were poor
and it was from that experience that
toby mundy the
editor of grove atlantic in england
who came up with this idea for a series
of books books that changed the world
uh of which the my book on adam smith is
one and christopher hitchens has one
also on on on thomas payne right it's a
man
and uh and very good it is um
it was because of of some adam smith
some poking around in adam smith that
toby asked me to write on adam smith
nesbitt mississippi you're on with p.j
o'rourke go ahead
nesbit you with us
hello come in nuzbet
tena fly new jersey go ahead
yeah i'm i am not sure why mr o'rourke
deserves to be taken seriously or be
given all of this time on your show
when a man who i suspect never wore the
uniform
and i suspect from hearing about his
politics in the vietnam era would have
done his darndest to avoid wearing the
uniform can be so utterly flippant about
war
we have a war now that we should not
have had by my lights and i happen to
have been a republican for 50 years
voting three times for richard nixon and
twice for ronald reagan
uh thousands of americans have been
killed tens if not hundreds of thousands
of iraqis have been killed
no useful purpose is served by this war
and i think it's abominable that mr
o'rourke can make fun of war and can
find something amusing about it but the
question i wanted to ask him is he talks
about the imperative of free markets
does mr
o'rourke have any conception about why
we have things like a minimum wage laws
and maximum hour laws and osha laws does
he remember the condition that existed
in america before we had those laws
and the way uh
uh laborers were obliged to work 12-hour
days six-day weeks is that what mr
o'rourke thinks is freedom
thank you caller um
mr work we'll get to the free market uh
question that he had in just a second
but in your i was one odd republican
it was on the democratic line next oh
okay i'm glad he came in on the
democratic line in uh your dedication to
give war a chance here's what you write
like many men of my generation i had an
opportunity to give war a chance and i
properly promptly chickened out i went
to my draft physical in 1970 with a
doctor's letter about my history of drug
abuse the letter was four and a half
pages long with three and a half pages
devoted to listing the drugs i'd abused
i was shunted into the office of an army
psychiatrist two at the end of a
45-minute interview with me was pounding
his desk and shouting you're effed up
you don't belong in the army he was
certainly right on the first count and
possibly right on the second
anyway i didn't have to go but that of
course meant someone else had to go on
my place i would like to dedicate this
book to him i hope you got back in one
piece fellow i hope you were more used
to your platoon mates than i would have
been
i hope you're rich and happy now and in
1971 when somebody punched me in the
face for being a long-haired peace creep
i hope that was you
i got a couple nice letters because of
that dedication from people who
thought maybe they had punched me in the
face
and said they appreciate it
uh to begin with the beginning of what
the fellow on the phone said
um i've never asked anybody to take me
seriously as to making fun of war
let's put it this way
a bad situation
and war is a really rotten situation
like a bad disease
like death itself
uh isn't changed by whether you make fun
of it or you don't
uh we make fun of things not because we
approve of them or love them
not because they're cuddly and cute we
make fun of things in order to cope with
our own terror our own unease
our own existential horror
our anger at god
our disappointment with ourselves etc
and so forth
humor is a defense mechanism you can you
can drink you can make a joke
you can take drugs you can uh
you can make yourself all pompous and
pious
or you can do all those things at once
so
whether i make fun of war or don't make
fun of war is unfortunately not going to
make war
better
and nor is it going to make war worse
as to
free market and minimum wage and
people working in coal mines and working
49 hours a day nine days a week and so
on and so forth
to
it's interesting when you say you're in
favor of free markets you immediately
get that response from lots of people
it's not of course at all what what adam
smith meant
uh what adam smith was talking about was
keeping coercion out of life and
keeping coercion out of marketplaces
is only one aspect of keeping coercion
out of life
adam smith's whole of
his
the wealth of nations the essays that he
wrote a very important book that he
wrote that no one reads anymore called
the theory of moral sentiments which is
about morality
was all about making people rely upon
persuasion
and to give up brute force
that is the core of morality
it's the core of a free society it's the
core of democracy even though adam smith
in some ways didn't know that he was he
lived in a pre-democratic era he didn't
quite understand that democracy could
work but he did understand that freedom
could work
he was a moral and a practical
and
and just a plain sort of sympathetic
advocate of freedom and at the root of
freedom is persuasion
the idea that you want free markets does
not mean that you want
markets ruled by force it does not mean
that you want markets ruled by anarchy
it implies a rule of law
and it implies that we are all equal
before that law
it is not prescriptive it doesn't tell
us exactly how to conduct the free
market it doesn't give us exact rules it
tells us that there should be rules and
that we should all obey the rules but it
doesn't say quite exactly what those
rules are in book five of the wealth of
nations adam smith actually tries to lay
down some rules he tries to take his
theories
and and make them prescriptive actually
give us political
uh
policy
he becomes a policy wonk
and uh it's interesting it's the one
failed book
in the wealth there are five books in
the wealth of nations fifth book stinks
uh when adam smith turns into a policy
wonk he becomes as foolish as
as as the rest of us do when we become
policy wonks he becomes
you know like they've had in this white
house and like they'll have in this
congress
so
um so to the very angry caller that
uh uh uh i i would just like to to to
say this uh
first i have no idea why
three hours should be wasted on me and
i'm not going to claim that there is a
good reason for it to ask me you know
what can i tell you
but
you know
because you have certain ideas about how
freedom should be conducted and you may
well be right and i respect those ideas
and those ideas are worth arguing about
they may not be the same ideas as i have
but don't just because you want to
limit certain freedoms in the market you
may be wise
and it may be the correct thing to do to
limit those freedoms
but
don't be smug about your desire to limit
freedom you know everybody who wants to
limit freedom
from those who desire that there be
human slavery to the to the taliban
to people who are in favor of minimum
wage laws everybody is smug about their
desire to to to limit human freedoms now
some human freedoms really do need to be
limited but that doesn't make you a good
person for recognizing that it may make
you a wise person or a sensible person
assuming your arguments are good
but you're not a good person you deserve
no smugness and you don't deserve to be
you know to vent your anger
on
foolish innocent humorous
just because you have some desire to
limit um so there
nesbitt mississippi thanks for holding
you're on with pizza
mississippi hey mr o'rourke it's a
pleasure to talk to you
how you doing uh doing good doing good
and just briefly if either that last
caller or
mr higgins had read your first book
they'd understand it's unseemly to
attack your betters this early on a
sunday
[Laughter]
when we all should be in church
exactly exactly well i felt this was a
worthy occasion to stay home and
uh get to have a conversation with you
one thing i wanted to ask you i'm
familiar with a lot of your work and one
of the uh
things that's so interesting to me is
just you know in your travels around
some of the people that you've worked
with
come across as very interesting
characters in your writing uh people
like tony's and i'm probably mangling
these names uh tony suau and uh yeah
tony's is a rough one tony suarez is
actually how you say although you'd
never know that from how he spells it
right
uh and i just it was i would be
interested in and
your take on some of the people that
you've traveled around with as you've
you know worked in all these oddball
locations over the years well i tell you
the the the interesting thing about that
to me is to work with real war
correspondents and real soldiers
uh just because i admire their courage
for one thing and also because i'm
utterly mystified about by it i i've
covered some wars and and some civil
disturbances but but i'm a writer and
writers get to duck
uh writers can get under the table with
no shame whatsoever plus we can make
things up you know we can cover uh the
term for it is uh is covering the war
from mahogany ridge that would be down
at the nearest bar
uh but you know of the various people
that that i've had the chance to work
with uh uh tony suarez one of my
absolute favorites he lives in paris now
he's an absolutely fat fabulous
photographer and he simply has
no fear
absolutely no fear and he and i were
covering um actually one of the most
dangerous stories i've ever covered it
wasn't a war
it was uh it was a student demonstration
of all things i mean i've been a student
demonstrator myself you know and i i
mean i know occasionally we got whacked
on the head and occasionally we got tear
gassed but this in korea this was in
korea during a presidential election and
i have never seen anything like these
student demonstrators they were armed
with iron pipes they're wearing
motorcycle helmets
they are fighting flat out with the
police i mean real fighting and they
took over a big municipal building they
got up on the roof and they're heaving
things off the roof
and i i a roof tile missed me by about
i was i was turned sideways to take a
note and it came by so close in front of
me that i could feel the breeze through
through the fly of my jeans
and so tony
in the middle of this says
i am going in
i am going to go in to this i'm going to
go into this municipal building through
all these angry students so i can be on
the other side so that i can see the
police come in so i can get a photograph
of the police
coming in storming through the building
with the tear gas and stuff he said
that's going to be great this is going
to be a fabulous photograph
we're upon
fortunately i think for tony
tony
in those days only weighed about 140
pounds
and i just i grabbed him by the back of
the photographer
jacket and pulled him out of there and i
said tony you know you're covering this
for me and i don't want that photograph
i don't care how good it is you know uh
we'll we'll we'll take some other
photograph you know uh and and i had to
physically res the guy's so courageous i
had to physically restrain him
another time he got me into the alaska
mosque in the middle of the first
intifada
disguised as a palestinian
well you're looking at me on tv now and
you sort of say i not the most
palestinian looking guy
in the entire world there i am i'm
dressed in a kaffiya i've got a robe on
and stuff
i did manage to pass
i'm standing out in the middle of the of
the dome of the rock uh in between the
dome of the rock and the alaska mosque
about 3 000 of us out there
i and
all of a sudden everybody but me is
facing mecca
and i thought well we'd better go with
it
and so everybody begins the muslim
prayer
and
so do i except
3 000 people are doing this in unison
and i'm half a beat behind
the only o'rourke to have ever prayed to
mecca
but hey
you know i'm sufficiently religious
person to feel that
there's one big guy up there
i'm and i'm sufficiently humble about my
theology that i don't know the details
so i figured it was all right
dallas good afternoon
hello i'm very very grateful for the
three hours
uh you're well thank you dallas
first book the first book i read was
holidays in hell and i remember almost
falling off the bed laughing thinking
this guy is a stupendous writer
and since that time i've
followed your books and
i
i also have studied a lot of the late
works of mark twain
and i
i just i see some some similarities and
some uh phraseology and and i wondered
if if uh you had read a lot of twain
that's my first question but i have
another question
well let's take them one at a time here
yes i have read a lot of mark twain and
i love mark twain although it's
interesting i i uh there there are parts
of twain i like much better than other
parts and i think you can probably tell
that uh uh that his that his travel
writing which is extraordinary and which
isn't read as much today as it ought to
be innocence abroad
has been a huge influence uh on me
i'm also of course very fond of of of as
i mean as every thinking person must be
uh of of huckleberry finn and of tom
sawyer
uh
i am not so fond of the o of later twain
uh i am particularly not fond of the
gilded age
there comes a moment when mark twain
begins feeling
that he has a moral message uh some of
his writing that wasn't published until
after his death is is even stronger in
this i mean he
he has a a a uh
he's angry at the world he's angry at
organized religion
um he's he start in a funny sort of way
he starts to take himself seriously um
i think this is a danger that every
humorist faces every
sancho ponza has got this skinny crazed
don quixote trying to fight his way out
you know so he can ride around on a mule
with a pot on his head you know tilted
windmills
and uh you know i i catch myself all the
time you know i think you know i think
uh uh you know i get by golly i'll show
that nancy pelosi what's what you know
and and then i think the pj come on
you're just a humorous
stop it you know
now your other question
oh okay the other question
uh i when you were foreign affairs
writer for rolling stone i subscribed
and and suffered the indignity of having
covers with naked people on them in my
mailbox no kidding read your writing uh
and you did a piece on
yugoslavia uh you were there
and i in fact put an excerpt from that
in my textbook the informed citizen and
really now after having been there
myself seven times
uh and seeing the aftermath of that
intervention
i'm uh
amazed that republicans
failed to point out in fact there's
almost a
there's a blackout on the word bosnia
and kosovo no one addresses the failed
policy of the clinton administration in
the balkans and right now i i would be
interested to know if you followed the
situation
peter o'rourke i certainly have followed
the situation and i've been there i
don't know
not as many times as you have but i i
have been to kosovo i've been to bosnia
a couple of times in albania uh uh also
and so at least four trips over there uh
i think that uh a couple of things are
gone there are a couple of reasons that
uh that the republicans have failed to
criticize uh clinton's policies which
were failed
one was that uh uh much as it as
clinton's policies were a failure over
there uh the larger failure was uh
really the eu i think after all it is
the eu's backyard and they should have
been the the front line they should have
been the main players on this
so they're probably more to blame than
clinton and we got we're in enough
fights with the eu i think without
bringing that up
more importantly
short public memory
people are going bazza what
base aware you go
you know nobody remembers anymore
even though the the aftermath of the
problem
is still very much with us and that's a
problem that could break out again at
any time i mean things are not
hunky-dory in in macedonia and and in
kosovo uh or albania either for that
matter or serbia or i could keep going
you know
and so uh uh you know the short public
memory is is part of it and i think the
third factor is that although the
republicans know that clinton and the eu
uh uh the that their policies were wrong
over there and they
probably at least the smarter
republicans if there are any left after
the last election um
uh
uh
know that this is a problem that could
recur you know they have the saying in
uh
in the area they say only the
odd-numbered world wars begin in the
balkans
uh but anyway i think the republicans
are a little flummoxed because they
don't know what to do after all you've
been there and you know just how
complicated that situation is
and the republicans don't have an easy
answer and since they're already in big
trouble for the iraq thing where they
thought they did have an easy answer
i think they're probably unwilling to
shoot their mouth off
over another place especially one where
they aren't going to gain any political
points
washington d.c you're on with p.j
o'rourke on in-depth good day
hi
mr o'rourke i think not having a memory
is your job
not having a memory is my job and ann
coulter and several other people in your
class
when you talk about free trade in the
founding of america 1750s english common
courts of philadelphia case it was
settled in england the illegality and
immorality of slavery was proved and
that economy was being destroyed by the
judicial third leg
on grounds of human rights so therefore
you can also make the case that the
founding of america was founded to
preserve slavery it's very simple to do
with w.b du bois or william pence laws
to get free from william penn you had to
work for 14 years and 75 percent of your
income
after that when you were freed was given
back to your tenant now let me continue
please when you talk about the 1960s the
1960s are voting rights for everyone in
the united states of america freedom of
speech and anti-war of six to eight
million people killed in vietnam in 1945
to be accurate and this comes from the
highest top one of the highest top
presidential advisers the guy who
brought einstein out of germany force in
1933
world war iii began in 1945.
try to think of the world this way and
you'll be much more clear
when you talk about mogadishu
you have to say 800 million dollars of
guns mine and mines and ammo was sent
there
from reagan bush for eight years
and when their guy was thrown out he
sent the marines in christmas eve 1992
and the first pardon in united states
history to stop an investigation was
handed down by george herbert walker
bush when you talk about the adriatic
coast the simplest way to say yugoslavia
no one remembers
i'm married to the daughter of the man
who jailed frankie tujma in the 1970s
for nazi insurrection january 1990 he
brought up the croat swastika the croat
yustashi militia the ss they were so bad
you can read all these things very
easily and the third largest death camp
in europe you got to know which so the
croat swastika was a rearm with 2
billion dollars from
george herbert walker bush and with arms
from helmut coleman all right
thank you for that call okay uh there
was a lot of interesting information
there and uh and for all i know all of
it was right i don't know why he's
arguing with me i don't know what i have
said to
to
set that off exactly um let's just take
one little point in there about slavery
um
uh slavery is a horrible blot on the uh
i mean is there any worse violation of
free markets and uh
and and of uh of economic freedoms
than the existence of slavery adam smith
was a very
active and effective
uh
uh
in his arguments against slavery
in the theory of moral sentiments he
destroys
any any justification for slavery on
moral grounds
and then in uh the wealth of nations he
destroys any pragmatic any any practical
grounds for slavery
one of the things that made him dubious
about the united states and he was
dubious about the united states he was
after all patriotic brett and he was
around right in the middle of the
little disturbances we were having back
in
1776 in fact
coincidentally uh wealth of nations came
out the same year of the declaration of
independence
and smith didn't think america could
work in part because of slavery and he
said
a republic
can never eliminate slavery because the
people who run a republic are exactly
the people who own the slaves of course
he was spot on with our founding fathers
not all of them but many of them
so
i don't know what the i mean i do know
what the caller was talking about but i
don't know why he was angry at me for
what he's talking about i i don't think
i've said anything to um
well i'm not exactly sure what his point
was but whatever his point was i don't
think i've said anything in an attempt
to contradict it
p.j o'rourke you've uh
generated quite a few emails
uh so far so here here are a couple of
them all right and this is from steven
lasky
at the reagan presidential library he is
the curator of general electric
promotional films there
i'll be darn okay
years ago you wrote a brilliant treatise
that held that santa claus is a democrat
and god is a republican
would you say this applies anymore given
the big tax cuts under every moneyed
family's christmas tree at a time of war
and rising deficits medicare
prescription pills in every stocking and
the bundles of cash that our new santa
has dropped on iraq and the gulf coast
to no discernible effect since it has
been hovered up by a gaggle of grinches
and are you enjoying the mercedes that
santa brought you last year
i should have been such a good boy
um
okay
i've got to recruise myself here for a
moment
because i fear
that
certain
small people whose names will go
unmentioned
might actually be watching dad
on so there are certain things about
which we can't speak
you get my dress how small are those
people
uh small enough uh to be of concern uh
uh uh uh
issue
yes exactly yes
okay so everybody's clear on this
anyway uh uh but to get to the point of
the matter is i would i could just
strangle the republicans not literally
of course we don't want
the secret service busting in here
republicans
in their years that they
since they took over congress have
proved themselves to be just a huge
wasters of money i mean just
unbelievable to me
particularly shocked by
the the the medicaid prescription drug
program
this is just an unbelievably large
giveaway and we don't even know how
large this large giveaway is going to be
the thing that really upsets me about
this is that there there's no effective
means testing in this it's a tiny little
bit of means testing we have the
economic capacity
in this country to make sure
that everybody gets medical care and
that nobody is beggared by getting the
medical care
all we have to do
is means test this no no no we're not
going to be able to make medical care
free the way hillary would like to make
it we're not going to even be able to
make it cheap
uh the way the rest of the democrats
would like it it's still going to be
expensive it's still going to hurt you
in your wallet but we but we do have the
capacity to make sure everybody gets
medical care when they need it and that
they're that they're not destroyed by
the cost and should we bankrupt it of
course we should of course we should i
mean conservative
as i am and and government minimalist
though i happen to personally be
government does have some
responsibilities to help people
when they cannot help themselves i don't
think these as rights
i think of these as responsibilities we
as citizens have responsibility to our
fellow citizens to help them when they
cannot help themselves not to help them
when it's inconvenient for them to help
themselves
not to help them when gosh they can't
they can't get a new car for three or
four years because of what this is
costing them
not to help them even if they have to
occasionally
put a second mortgage on the house
but to keep them from being destroyed to
keep them from being homeless to keep
them from being
absolutely impoverished
by their medical bills yeah we have that
responsibility and we have the capacity
to do it but not if we give everything
away to i'm a couple of years away from
from from medicare you're pushing 60
this year i am and and all this stuff
comes to me free whether i can you know
afford it or not
that's wrong that's just wrong
just as farm subsidies you know for
wealthy farmers are wrong just as
corporate welfare is wrong
so no i'm furious i've kind of gotten
off the point i mean i'm furious at the
republicans for their their their
inclination not their inclination to
spend the fact of their spending the
fact of their spending is atrocious how
old are the kids
they are uh you're supposed to know this
aren't you
they're nine they're six and a half
and the little guy will be three on
groundhog day and uh what are their
names elizabeth olivia and cliff and who
is mrs o'rourke this is o'rourke uh knee
tina mallon
a a former pr executive in this fair
town
and now i
stay at home
stay home everything as a matter of fact
she is the uh she she's the actual ceo
and she's not on the sofa
and you you married in 1995 married in
1995.
are you a wealthy man
no i'm yeah
moderately prosperous i've managed to
make a pretty decent living
from something that it is not easy to
make a pretty decent living from on the
other hand it's kind of a continuing
struggle it's not not one of those you
don't just like hit it
uh people think you know if you have one
best-selling book that somehow or other
that
forever after checks will keep coming in
the mail well forever after it turns out
to be about six months
and then checks get littler and little
litter until they finally go away
completely
so like anybody who writes for a living
i have to do a bunch of different things
you know i have to work on books i have
to write magazine stuff i do some
business speaking put it all together it
makes a a reasonable living but then how
how
you know it's it doesn't come with any
sort of like how do you get out of it
you know you stop you know
oh well well christopher bray in the
london telegraph quotes you in 2005
saying writing is agony i hate it
is that an accurate quote absolutely
i love thinking about writing
figuring out something to write that's a
lot of fun i love having written oh boy
look at what i wrote it's
the actual doing of the thing is just
dean spraguens
graduated from the air force academy in
1975 lives in hill city south dakota
could pj expound on his relationship
with the military as an organization and
with individual members how has his
opinion been transformed over the years
in turn what do the men and women in the
military think of him well i can't ask
uh excuse me
i can't answer the last part i have no
idea
um but
my relation with the military actually
started fairly early when they tried to
draft me but i'm not counting that
um
during the during the 60s it's kind of
forgotten now there was a fair
amount of anti-war agitation
within
especially the enlisted ranks
and not just the enlisted ranks there
were there were officers too who were
especially as the vietnam war started to
go south and it became increasingly
pointless
i had a very close friend in college uh
who was a marine corps uh uh infantry
officer he's a lieutenant
and uh uh
what about ten years after the war was
over um
we were up drinking late one night and
he said you know there's something that
that happened in vietnam that i've never
told anybody about i thought oh oh you
know
what did my pal do
and uh i said look you know
uh you know we've been friends for a
long time
and if you want to talk about this
let's you know uh he said you know i'm
not
um you know you're my friend not here to
judge you and i'm but i've got my
fingers crossed that this is not
something that is going to turn my
stomach all i can think of is mila and
so on
and his secret
and the thing of guilt that he had been
carrying with him
was he used to take his platoon out and
hide them
he said i love these guys in my platoon
they were draftees
they didn't know from nothing this is
late in the war
nothing good is going to come of this
he said i'd take him out and we'd go out
around the corner and rice paddy and
we'd hunker down smoke cigarettes
and then we'd come back and tell stories
oh yeah you know we
yeah we caught some
north vietnamese here and so on so forth
that was the guilt that he'd carried i
thought bless your soul you know
um
my yeah
i've always liked those guys my parents
were in the military a lot of my
relatives were in the military
and then
when i actually saw them in action uh
when i first saw the american military
in action which was fairly late in my
career i had covered the civil war in
lebanon and
and problems in the uh guerilla warfare
in the in the philippines and various
other
blow-ups and dust-ups and so on i didn't
really see the american military in
action until um the first gulf war 91
and um
they're great they're just great they're
absolutely great and then i saw him
again in bosnia i saw him again in
somalia
the uh the
the current war um i've been absolutely
uh uh
impressed
top to bottom
they're
gentlemanly they're professional
uh god knows they're brave well we knew
they were brave already
um
and i've always gotten along with them
fine um
with this caveat
i don't like the whole embedded thing
i'm a reporter
it's my job to go look
for stories good bad or indifferent i'm
supposed to i really have only one brief
which is to tell the truth
if you embed me in a unit as an
essentially part of that unit
there's no way i am not psychologically
going to become part of that team
i am not going to tell on you guys i'm
going to see you in danger
i i'm going to see you
frightened i'm going to see
me real frightened
there's every probability you're going
to save my life because i'm an idiot you
know and i'm i'm 60.
you know
and then i mean if i see you do
something wrong i'm not going to tell on
you i'm just too human for that i just i
i just couldn't do it
so
that's not the best thing to do to a
reporter
and and and and so when it came around
to to the to the gulf war i had no
interest in in in being embedded which
meant i got to spend most of the army of
the the iraq war
i got to spend most of it in
festive interesting
kuwait
in give war a chance p.j o'rourke writes
it's important to remember that the 1991
u.s military is not made up of oliver
stone and his hooch-torching platoon of
hop-heads these young men and women were
barely born then they're the reagan kids
they took one look at the 60s leftovers
which littered their childhoods and said
give me a haircut and a job they've got
skills training education and if they
just quit calling me sir and telling me
quote you're the same age as my mom
they'd be the salt of the earth mourinho
valley california thanks for holding
you're on with pj o'rourke
hey pj how are you i'm well and yourself
well you know your books are great but
you do much better on tv
do i
i i think i've kind of got the looks for
radio myself but uh you know while you
do but
the reason i'm i'm mentioning that is
your mind's very fast and i think that's
why you have trouble with the writing
part
because your mind is very quick
bless you for that excuse i thought i
was just lazy and sometimes drunk
but now i know that it's actually that
my mind is too quick and i believe me
i'm stealing that and i'm using it
marietta ohio go ahead
hi pj how you doing i'm fine marietta i
know marietta ohio oh great well i've
got something completely different for
you here okay uh as a miami alumnus yes
you have any reflections on your college
days uh
seems to me oxford was not exactly a
hotbed of radical descent even in the
late 60s and
also what do you think of the brouhaha a
few years ago on
political correct naming of the sports
team
redskins are good enough for d.c
what's what's the new name of the uh
miami dust bunnies
the dust bunnies no
they're called standing redskins
redhawks they tried the tribe and that
was still that was still not good enough
that still wasn't correct then they went
to red hawks which i have no idea what
that has anything to do with i don't
even think it's a bird is it is there
such a thing as a red hawk i don't know
there's a red shouldered hawk i think
cause that'd be an awkward football team
no miami was hardly a hotbed of
radicalism
as a matter of fact i would say around
about 1966 or 67 i probably this is a
campus of 10 000 students
i probably knew everyone who smoked pot
by name
you could fit them all in this studio
with no problem whatsoever
um
but uh nonetheless a few of us managed
uh you know to to fake a sort of 60s
hippie existence in the in in the middle
of this
bucolic campus with uh with these
incredibly pretty co-eds and these uh
and these nice straightforward business
major uh
uh uh fraternity guys and some pretty
good sports teams and i don't know what
we were thinking but we managed to make
a make a a squalid little mini berkeley
all our own albeit it only consisted of
about two rented houses but um
it was hard work
and you grew up in toledo i grew up in
toledo yes were you close to your
parents
yes i was but my but uh uh in a sense uh
my father died wasn't quite nine my
father died and my mother was sick a lot
of my about a year
after my father and i had a year and a
half after my father died she was
diagnosed with cancer they gave her a
year to live at that time she did not
die then
but
she had quite a few health problems and
did eventually
died in the early 70s
and she had three
thoroughly ungrateful and badly behaved
uh
uh children to raise mostly on her own
and um
one stepfather in there wasn't up to
much and um
yeah so it was uh so in a way i wasn't
close to them i mean not not because i
didn't like them or because i was
rebelling or anything like that but one
was dead and the other was busy uh close
to your sisters today
yeah we're pretty close you know i mean
you know you know that's sort of like uh
pushing 60 brother and sister sort of
way you know
one more email and then we're going to
visit pj o'rourke's apartment and talk
about his writing habits
this is from richard torregrosa of san
diego what is the most enjoyable aspect
of what you do professionally and the
least enjoyable the actual writing the
reaction from fans publishing publicity
promotion business of books book
signings etc
well the least enjoyable part really is
the writing and writing is just hard
work and it's not because my mind's too
quick believe me
it is just
writing requires a couple of o of of
skills
uh
neither of which i i i i'm overly
blessed with
uh one is that the the that
it's a it's almost a three-way
translation we think
we don't really think in words we think
mostly in images and concepts and just
in order to speak we have to translate
the thoughts into words this in of
itself is difficult witness our
president of the united states who
can't be a dumb guy i mean he's just not
a dumb guy he he he went to good schools
he did
better than i did at
and i went to much worse schools
he obviously have some trouble turning
his mental concepts into words as many
people do take pull a person off the
street put him behind a podium in front
of an audience of a thousand and see
what happens it's tough
then in order to put this down in paper
on paper you have to take the words that
you speak it's yet another language we
really operate in three languages the
language of thought the language of
speech and and the written language
which is different more formal
also the written language
lacks hand gestures
it lacks facial expressions
it lacks context it's simply naked there
on the page
therefore
anything that's put down on the page
whether it's a joke or a profound
insight into human nature whether no
matter what it is it has to be
organized
in a way
that is far more rigid and formal
than
speech or thought so it's tough it's
tough and i don't know anybody
who's writing it i at all respect who
says they love to write i suspect the
only people who love to write are
bloggers
and
um you know it's it
blog you know blogs are blogs are free
and worth it um uh the um
now what do i like best
is
what i like best is that though the one
thing that being a reporter a journalist
if you will or whatever
gives you which is just an access to all
sorts of stuff in life that you would
never ever get a chance to see as a
as an ordinary citizen
i mean we are professional rubber
neckers we get to go look at the car
wreck that everybody else has to stand
behind the police tape well that's maybe
not the prettiest you know so sort of
but but we get to go
go places and do things that other
people
don't get to do
certain kind of people like soldiers get
to do some things that other people
don't get to do they get to play with
some pretty cool toys they get to fly
the chinooks
of course to get shot at too
but a journalist gets to do everything
practically anything and just the i mean
how else would i ever have gone to 70
different countries and some of them
rather oddball little countries too uh
you know if it hadn't been for for for
for being a reporter so that's the best
part
here's pj o'rourke in his washington dc
apartment talking about his writing
habits
when you're working on a book
what's a typical day like for you
i just get up and go right to it uh i
get up have a cup of coffee and go to
work and that's that
i find i've got about
four hours of limited intelligence uh
and and many more hours another 20 of of
of no intelligence at all and so i have
to get get moving
right in the morning and if things go
well in that first three or four hours
then i can then push through for the
rest of the day uh but but if i try and
start if i try and do something first
even something as i'm forever explaining
to my wife something as simple as take
the kids to school or make them
breakfast
or even get their little
their their little boots and hats on
my concentration is destroyed for the
day
that's my story and i'm sticking to it
we're in washington now you do most your
writing in new hampshire we're we live
most of the time in new hampshire i mean
new hampshire is our real residence we
keep a
apartment in in washington because i
have to be down here on business fairly
often that's our excuse the fact is we
we we've been in this building on
connecticut avenue forever my wife and i
both lived here before before we met
and we both love the building and we
love the apartment and we just can't
bring ourselves to give up the apartment
even though it sits here empty
but the kids are in school in new
hampshire and so therefore we are
married to new hampshire
for the school year and then come summer
and only a maniac would be in washington
in the summer if he didn't have to so
you know
so we're at this we live in new
hampshire
behind you is a typewriter an ibm's
electric three
that is how you do your writing not only
is that how i do my writing this is one
of about five that i own
because
friends of mine over the years have of
course adopted modern technology and
gone to computers and given up their
ibm's electrics for which there is no
market whatsoever and they give them to
me
and so i have there's one stored around
here and there there i think there are
three in the attic in new hampshire so
um
when um when it breaks
and it will event sturdy though they are
it will eventually break and and someday
all the people who can fix them will
have died off
i've got spares
you must have friends who are writers
who who tell you that you're crazy to
use a typewriter what's what's that
conversation like how do you defend
yourself well um
i i
actually
i defend myself with something that
stephen king said um and and i i don't
know stephen king and i i don't really
like
horror
stories
i'm not a huge stephen king fan i mean
he seems like a very nice man and so on
so forth but stephen king said when he
first got a computer some years back he
said oh my gosh he said this is amazing
i could have written three times the
amount of stuff that i've written if i
just had a computer and i thought
saints forbid
the last thing on earth that i want is
three times as many you know um um
cujos
running around on the library no offense
it's stephen king he's uh he's you know
he's a he's a credit to our profession i
i i i wish him well i i i don't mean to
insult him but i don't you know
three times as much jane austen maybe
you know but somehow i feel that having
a computer would not have generated
three times as much jane austen for jane
when you're working during the day on a
book you say you try to wait for four
hours um
well actually when i try and write i try
and write a budget i try and write a
thousand words a day
uh
oh no in a splendid ideal world that
takes four hours and i can goof off for
the rest of the day which never happens
unfortunately more often takes twelve
but i try to write
a thousand words a day but it's that
first four hours today three or four
hours you know
time between waking up and launch that
one my brain seems to work slightly
better
how about uh your reference material you
mentioned to me earl before we were
recording that you have an encyclopedia
britannica i have i not only have a
segment an encyclopedia or tank actually
got a couple i've got the very i've got
a facsimile of the original edition 117
whatever
which is great it's three volumes and
contains no information they didn't know
anything back there uh and i've got a
1945 edition that i picked up in some
junk store which is is all right you
know i um um
but the one that i prize and that i go
to all the time is i have a 19 i have
the 11th edition of the encyclopedia
britannica which came out of the
american edition which came out in 1911.
and that's a great moment in human
history because they knew everything
and they were perfectly certain about it
all and so whenever you want to be
certain about something really certain
about something you look it up in the in
the 11th edition of the encyclopedia
britannica and there it is no ifs no
buts no
you know no no shading no
no no weasel words no no no wiggling
a thousand words a day how does the
revision process work for you
i i used to be an editor for living i'm
i'm a quick reviser i'm a quick editor
i'm a slow writer
writing is no fun whatsoever and it
takes me a long time but once i've got a
rough draft i'm pretty i'm pretty happy
that it's
that's very much the other side of the
slope
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
we are back on in depth we have about
another two hours with our guest pj
o'rourke author of 12 books his most
recent is on adam smith p g o'rourke on
the wealth of nations we're going to put
the phone numbers up on the screen 202
is the area code for all of our numbers
737.002 if you are a democrat 737 triple
zero one if you're republican and
628-0205 for all others booktv cspan.org
is our email address mr o'rourke here's
another email this is from rebecca
hodson of manistee michigan
my friends and i are part of the local
young republicans organization and we
have just one burning question
if you must vote democrat
obama or clinton
obama clinton
well
i got to go with obama just for the
novelty
factor uh i feel like
i don't want to i don't want hillary
clinton in office mainly because i don't
want to read another one of her darn
books
uh it isn't really that i have any
abiding republican hatred for her
no we don't agree about stuff but you
know i don't agree i'm not going to
agree with obama either but i haven't
read his books
and i have read hers and i don't want to
have to read anymore so
let's get her off the stage and get him
and just for novelty value plus you know
i mean we are in the news business he's
new
she's not new
in the last hour drinking and drugs have
been mentioned 17 times so far in this
program here's here's an email that came
in from just kidding don't kids don't do
this at home heidi morgan emails in
a person with the kind of drug pass that
you have of which as a 54 year old
californian have also had some exposure
to especially the hallucinogenic ones
m wondering how you view the whole
public treatment of drug use and what if
anything should be happening to the laws
legalization it's really the only answer
i mean we are we have a sort of de facto
legalization
in in one sense
um
is this actually
talk about immigration for a moment just
because there's a parallel here i was
talking to some friends of mine in texas
there are rich republican friends of
mine
in texas they have ranches down along
the border they are finding dead people
on their ranches they are
not happy about this
they they're doing what they can to make
sure that i mean when they find somebody
lost on their ranches and these are
these are big ranches um they give them
food and water they don't hand them over
to immigration so i thought these people
very conservative i thought they would
be anti-immigration
not at all the case
for one thing many of them speak spanish
they have an affinity for the culture
and some of them as it turned out i
talked to them some of them are
partly spanish
mexican heritage themselves
but the point that they made
about immigration was it
give us some kind of system where people
are sorted in the daylight so we're
going to people are going to come into
the united states we need to take a look
at them let us sort them in the daylight
make there a process where people can
legally come into the united states that
isn't
incredibly hard
same things with drugs i mean there are
probably some drugs we shouldn't have
around they're going to cause more
trouble
than the libertarian side of them being
legal is worth
methamphetamine looks like a candidate
you know
and who wants a drug that makes you stay
awake and work longer anyway um
let's sort these drugs in the daylight
when you make them all illegal
you
incapacitate denver colorado you're on
with pj o'rourke go ahead
pj
you wrote a like for me a life-changing
article in the early 80s for car and
driver magazine
i apologize in advance here
for whatever happened to your life after
that
it kicked off a lifelong love affair
ferraris and you're riding oh well thank
you you you drove a car from uh new
jersey to los angeles i did a 308
ferrari yeah yeah you were national
lampoon at the time i was what i'm
curious about is how you went from
what was basically a wild man
to actually a semi-serious
thinker who hides behind humor
it would just age
just age you know i mean the whole wild
man thing just kind of ceases to to work
out after a while you know you can't
stay up to
to to be wild anymore or you know or or
or if you try and be wild then you can't
get to sleep like you want to uh it just
sort of wears out you know you need you
need an act too in in there somewhere
now
uh act two is usually pretty pathetic
and
i have a feeling mine is also but to not
have an act two means to wind up like
hunter thompson
i knew hunter thompson
very well and i loved him he and he was
a really great guy
but
hunter did not have it figured out what
to do after 50. there's about that
there's no doubt
um our 54 year old hallucinogenic
californian is sent in a second email
which fits what vehicle would you drive
now if you were drinking and driving as
per your short story in national
employment oh limousine
put somebody out front of course more
probably it would be a taxi cab but you
know what i mean
santa barbara california good afternoon
oh hi mr aurora guy it's great to talk
to you i want to thank you for writing
eat the rich it actually got me into
economics in high school and i followed
that path
what i wanted to ask is to what do you
chalk up the widespread misconceptions
about and misunderstanding of the
subject of economics caller caller how
old are you now i'm 22. thanks
uh
got it in one i've got it in one word
uh well no two words
zero sum
zero sum thinking is the abiding sin of
attitudes towards economics which is
simply this for for those of you not uh
in the audience not familiar with with
the term
the idea that wealth is a pizza and if i
eat too many slices you're going to have
to eat the domino's box that's zero-sum
thinking
and probably the greatest single
contribution that adam smith made to
economics
was to get rid of the idea
that that that wealth is a certain set
fortune
that has to be divided we hear this over
and over again particularly from the
democratic side of the aisle but not
just there how you know wealth isn't
well distributed in america as though
wealth were a fixed amount and we were
cutting up that pie and some people's
pie slices were way too thin and some
peoples were way too fat it isn't at all
how wealth works there is an infinite
amount of wealth there isn't an infinite
amount of everything some things are
zero-sum
uh my wife
mess
around there and i'll shoot you you know
i mean
there's there's just one of her and i
love her and i'm keeping her
but that's not the case with wealth
the idea is of course very basic and
almost instinctual in humans because
originally wealth was based on land
first on hunting and gathering then of
course on agriculture and there is a
fixed amount of land and so it is deeply
ingrained in the human psyche and in
human sociology to regard wealth as zero
sum because back when it was land any
land that i had that i got i had to take
from you i had to steal your backyard
but once modern economy the economy of
manufacturing things and of services
of goods and manufactured goods and and
services provided began to develop
which it did during the late middle ages
wealth suddenly became non-zero sum and
it was adam smith was the first person
to really fully uh
understand that
and boy an awful lot of people out there
from nancy pelosi right on down don't
seem to understand it yet
tempe arizona you're on with pj o'rourke
uh good afternoon mr o'rourke hi how you
doing oh we're just doing wonderfully uh
i was just very pleased when i saw your
list of influences as being tom wolf
and who of whom i'm a great admirer as
well and the fact that you possess an
11th edition britannica which i also do
too
it came to me in the late 70s and i just
love it it's still a great great
reference and i agree with you about its
certitude
yeah that's the thing is again for you
know for people who may not be familiar
with this
is the uh uh
in uh uh the early 1900s the
encyclopedia britannica came out with
the 11th edition and they had everybody
i mean that bertrand russell and all the
top authorities that they could find
write the articles for this and but the
thing that's
good about it is not only is the
information in there correct insofar as
it could be in 1911 obviously a few
things have been learned since then and
quite a few things have been forgotten
but people have made no bones about
being right when they were
there was no conditionality to this was
not many say some think
each of these articles in there just
lays down the law this is what a
cathedral is this is how they're built
this is how you cut a stone this is how
you make steel this is you know this is
what ontology means
whatever is in there and it's just such
a comfort ah it's not always right but
it's so comforting to open up a book
where people have the sort of confidence
of their
their their convictions they are hedging
all over the place no wikipedia is is
the uh encyclopedia britannica 11th
edition
you've uh
dis blogs and wikipedia or do you use
the internet
no i have no idea how to use the
internet i i don't even know how to i
have really never used the computer i
think years ago at rolling stone to edit
something i i
at some last minute as it was going to
press i think i used
the the computer there as a little bit
as a word processor and of course that
was you know back in the days when they
were you know huge
and huge and slow
uh i don't i don't know how to use them
um at all i suppose one of these days
i'm gonna have to find out because
basically the reference library has
moved to to to to to the internet and
and it's there's really no choice
but i just don't like the whole thing i
don't like you know communication i'm in
the communication business i know it's
limited value an excess of communication
worse than an excess of booze or drugs
can you get parts for your selectric too
i have better than parts for my
selectric too i have about six of them
because as friends of mine went to
computers they would give me their
ibm's electrics
and so i've got them stockpiled i've got
i think i've got two or three in
washington i've got
three or four in there something like
that plus i do know a guy up new
hampshire still knows how to fix them so
why tom wolf was the only person you put
down is most influenced uh your career
well it was it was just a it wasn't an
aesthetic matter it's it's not i mean i
like tom wolfe's writing you know and
and i admire tom wolf but it's not that
he blew me away in some i mean no he
wasn't like my keats or shelley or
anybody those probably aren't
the best uh uh uh uh examples but i mean
for me
a person that just knocked me out when i
first discovered him was evelyn wall
but
tom wolf had a practical influence on me
i was in graduate school at johns
hopkins and i was going to something
called the writing program which was a
complete waste of time i got into
fellowship to go to graduate school and
i had looked around
for the easiest graduate program to take
and i found this writing program at
johns hopkins that really seemed to be
uh you know
it didn't seem to have any requirements
basically it was only a year long i
thought great this is perfect i take my
fellowship and and run with it there
and because i was going to be a poet and
a writer and i knew that really all i
wanted was just uh uh you know some some
money so i could could write
incomprehensible prose and and rhymeless
poetry and junk
so i'm beavering away at all this and i
began to realize sometime that
year that i just didn't have any talent
i just didn't have any talent for
for fiction and um or poetry
it just wasn't there
but i did have a little knack for
journalism i started to write a few
little pieces for underground newspaper
and a couple things
and a little you know conceivable knack
and i wouldn't go so far as to call it a
talent but i i i didn't outright stink
at
non-fiction
and it was just about this time when i
was kind of humbled and a little worried
about what i was going to do with my
life because i thought i was going to be
james choice or something
and that that wasn't happening
and god knows the world doesn't need
another one of him anyway but uh or
probably another one of me either but
never mind uh
tom wolfe comes along or i first read
tom wolfe and i realize
gee you can write non-fiction stuff and
it can really be interesting i mean
there are interesting
things that you can do it doesn't have
to be
art
there are things that you can do with
mirror craft
that are fun
next call for pg o'rourke new orleans go
ahead
yes just go wrong how you doing down
there you you bailed out yet
i'm sorry i didn't hear quite what you
said have you bailed out down in new
orleans i mean how's the how's the did
you get the house up a little higher
than it was before
well that's why i'm calling good
i am a physician
which means i can make money i have not
made money since the storm my wife is an
attorney
she's struggling i guess is the word
yeah
and i am working right now actually i
had to take time out i had to make the
choice do i hang on the line to talk to
you or do i keep working
the bottom of my house
is still
completely gutted i'm walking through a
very
horrific landscape
all around us is horrific
anyway my real call is i think you've
put new orleans
in the same
category
as iraq
basically saying that we screw up
therefore we don't need money
uh just like a rock
and i really have to say i take great
offense at this i have work no no i
didn't say that i didn't say i actually
didn't even mention iraq no no i mean i
would say that you guys down there are
victims of of government incompetence
that's like i mean just
mind-boggling you know and uh i suppose
the only thing i can say in its favor is
that it was bipartisan uh you know so
therefore it shows that that it's not
just republicans or just democrats who
are idiots uh it does pretty much indict
the entire political system but
no i didn't say a word about not giving
money to new orleans
on our republican line washington d.c
hello
in your
1998 book eat the rich you visited
various countries and you talked about
how their economies were doing and i
wonder how some of them might have
changed or stayed the same since then
well you know i i i i tell you honestly
haven't checked
some of the places that were really
messed up uh really really messed up
were so messed up that they weren't
going to get unmessed up anytime soon
such as haiti
there's no doubt about that but uh uh
in some cases like tanzania i think a
fair amount of progress has has been
made
uh one thing that that i actually in
some ways more interested in in in going
back to that book then then what kind of
progress the individual countries had
made
was uh where i went wrong in my analysis
in that book and i think that
and russia would be a pretty good
example in there i don't think i gave
adequate emphasis to the rule of law how
important the rule of law is to economic
growth i just wasn't looking in that
direction i think you know i i talked
about it in a few places but i didn't
really get
that at a gut level and i got to say
that adam smith was an important
education for me in that respect
in eat the rich you recount a story a
little before curfew on my last night in
albania i was sitting in a cafe with the
wire service reporter and a couple of
other fellow stateside hacks
albanians are just like anybody else i
was saying they're crazy said the wire
service reporter no they're not i said
they just have a different history
different traditions a different set of
political and economic circumstances
they're acting exactly the way we would
if we
there was an albanian family at the next
table handsome young husband pretty wife
baby in a stroller cute four-year-old
girl bouncing on her dad's knee the girl
grabbed the cigarette from between her
father's lips and tried to puff mom and
dad laughed dad took the cigarette back
then he pulled a pack of marlboros from
his shirt pocket offered a fresh
cigarette to the little girl and gave
her a light is that a true story honest
to god
absolutely why did you include that and
eat the rich because i wanted to show
that maybe some people are crazy
it's just
you know the the thing about uh
about being a reporter is that
you
can only go
so deep with this stuff we're not
psychiatrists we're not we're not
sociologists we're not anthropologists
all you can do is report what you see
and sometimes it's very important to
remind yourself not just go making great
big conclusions you know i mean i i i'm
not
i don't have the intellectual stature to
go around say all people and societies
are exactly alike and so on and so here
i am making this case to this wire
service reporter that
these are people are just like us
which is something i do fundamentally
believe about most people
but and then you see something that was
just so
damn
odd
you know i've had i've had this
experience a couple of times you know
um
in korea uh during that the the story i
told earlier at the same time during
that that presidential election
i was uh up on the stand with one of the
uh uh presidential candidates and there
was a rally unbelievably large rally
300 400 000 people at this political
rally more people i've ever seen in one
place or hope to again
bitter cold day
unattractive
a day again and these people are
cheering wildly down at the very front
of this is a fellow in a white ski
jacket
and during this political rally while
the presidential candidate is speaking
he takes the ski jacket off
bites off the end of his little finger
and writes the name of the presidential
the character for the presidential
candidate's name on the back of his ski
jacket and i wrote in rolling stone i
said i've been a foreign reporter for a
long time and this is the first time
i've ever seen anything that was really
effing foreign
so i mean sometimes you just run into
these things where you go now what on
you know i mean yeah i mean my job's to
be the explainer but i mean sometimes
you just run into stuff you know
what it means
in peace kills you discuss you have a
conversation with somebody about whether
or not there are inferior cultures
oh yeah well and i can't remember which
side i came out on on that
yeah actually you know what it comes
down to is because they're not inferior
people and they're not inferior types of
people but yeah there are some cultures
that are inferior i have been around
some very dangerous angry cultures there
are my irish drunk irish uncles you know
just for starts you know anybody who's
been to a public a large public high
school knows there are some inferior
cultures the hitters the greasers you
know i mean
they're not getting into med school
are they on average
as bright as the you know
i went to a big public high school i
went to the village high school in
toledo ohio named for the man who
invented the
paint spray gun thomas de velveus
um
who was this eye ear and nose and throat
specialist
who originally invented a little thing
you could spray stuff down your throat
with and from that came the automatic
spray gun and that's how everything gets
painted today
so thomas devils high school and we had
a very broad range of kids
and among those kids
there was a fair contingent of kids from
appalachia families were from appalachia
come up to work in the in the car plants
and the carpark plants in toledo
and those kids were tough
they were really tough
and they did not do well in school
now were they somehow genetically
different
from the kids who are in advanced
placement english have that in those
days but you know what i mean
no
among other things they're as waspy as
anybody could be i mean you know you
know if you if you took this sort of
like upper middle class well-off waspy
protestant kids
those mix were in between somewhere
mixing the italians were like kind of
smart kind of stupid
but the appalachian kids really acted
stupid and then there were these sort of
like you know protestant kids from nice
neighborhoods
to really smart
was genetically identical they come out
from from the same gene pool they all
came over on the mayflower it's just you
know some of them headed up into the
hills and some didn't you know
on average they could not have been any
different
and yet their cultures
were very different one culture prized
hitting
one prize getting into college
so there are inferior cultures
indianapolis you're on with pg o'rourke
uh hi mr o'rourke how are you today i'm
fine how are you i'm great thank you
uh my question is uh a little more
sentimental i suppose
america certainly lost one of its own
originals when hunter s thompson passed
away could you
characterize your relationship with him
and could you comment briefly on
what you
how you perceive his reach in america do
you think he was limited
by an exposure to a younger more
subversive audience and because
all those young subversives now work for
television studios and magazines do you
think that he
unintentionally influenced a lot of the
drivel that unfortunately pervades so
much popular journalism today
yeah you know it is probably the fate of
every really great artist
to be a bad influence
jackson pollock
can you imagine a worse influence i mean
think of the years
of
paint being splattered around
uh by
college art students you know that
resulted from jackson pollock and yet
you go see a jackson pocket you really
see he really was a genius
there was an obit for hunter that i
thought was absolutely just brilliant
and i don't remember who wrote it it was
a guy from the cleveland plain dealer
and i don't even remember how i happened
to see this
but anyway it was the best obit that was
written about him and he talked about
how hunter thompson made being a
reporter
hip and cool and and somehow kind of
dangerous
and
and he and he goes on in this fame for a
little while and he said i just you know
i said it was hunter thompson
that caused a certain reporter
whom we shall not name to show up on his
first day in the job
and to go to a cleveland
sewer
council
committee meeting dressed in sunglasses
and a hawaiian shirt
obviously talking about himself you know
and hunter did have a a bad influence in
a way i would say the worst influence
that hunter had was the idea that people
got from his writing that you could get
stoned and do stuff that would be
absolute genius that you the the the the
that that drugs and booze and staying up
late at night
and uh and
and firing guns off to the ceiling
made you
a good writer i mean that's you know i
mean that's like a very basic logical
fallacy that's the uh uh
uh the the good writer takes a lot of
drugs therefore if i want to be a good
writer i should take a lot of drugs you
know and uh
the why hunter was good was that hunter
had read everything it absolutely read
everything and he and he had a
tremendous memory for it he also had an
absolutely brilliant ear he had a jazz
musicians here he was a he was a poet
hunter was primarily a poet and he was
an absurdist
and and hunter would get mad at me a
little bit when we would talk about this
because and this is
hunter and i were pretty close
i i met hunter back in the 70s and and
we'd see each other fairly often and
what we talked about was literature
uh we didn't talk about drugs and guns
and although i i happened to like guns
all right you know
but
this is not what we talked about
we would talk about poetry and and
and prose and mostly about fiction and
um
and we were both big fans of the of some
of the beat poets and especially the
earlier stuff and and um
just had a fabulous ear for this
but somewhere along the line he
he got the idea that there was a a a
some an important political side to what
he did and and and and i i was never
convinced by that
just never convinced by law i could
never understand what he was getting at
i i would say to him sometimes i said
hunter this is all very interesting your
criticisms of of society and
and and business and politics and stuff
are
quite accurate you know well not
accurate i mean you know they're they're
they're
but they're marvelous criticisms and and
they have substance
and what is your alternative
to this and see as long as you're
willing to to stay being an absurdist
whatever your alternative is is
meaningless i mean that's that's not
what you're doing
but but hunter had an idea that his
criticisms were meaningful and and that
of course requires an alternative system
what on god green earth
would hunter's alter alternative
political system be what would he have
done if he had become sheriff of aspen
county
beats me
jeffrey eisenhower emails in from
washington great name i was sending the
you should run for something
it's with an eye
i was in the military for 10 years and
i've enjoyed you in writing and speaking
for several years as a result of my
military training i can repair ibm
selectrix and i live in dc just so you
know some of us are around we'll give
you this email what was the biggest
surprise you found while writing about
wealth of nations
biggest surprise i found about right
wealth of nations was that that at the
core of the book wasn't about economics
that it was about morality
and then early on someone had suggested
in fact it was a specific guy tom palmer
at the uh at the cato institute who was
a real adam smith scholar
and and to whom i had gone for advice
about writing this book
tom said to me um
you've got to go read the theory of
moral sentiments uh that you're not
going to understand the wealth of
nations unless you read the theory of
moral sentiments and several other
people told me the same thing including
charles murray and
i don't remember who else i i think
it was
chris demuth who has aei
anyway all in all every everybody i
talked to who really knew their adam
smith said go get the theory of moral
sentiments of which i had never heard
well it turns out
that adam smith
thought of himself not as an economist
but as a philosopher
and he had an idea for a philosophical
project it was to to it was to be three
great big big books
it was a book on morality on how we
create moral systems and how we can
better exercise
our morality under those systems
about our material circumstances how we
manage to
generate wealth and how we can generate
more of it and on politics or as he
called it juris prudence he didn't make
it all the way through uh uh he only did
the first two books and i i talk a bit
in in the wealth of nations about why
there's no third book i mean part of
it's because he died make it very hard
to write the book but also i think he
lost heart in the idea about ge about
jurisprudence about politics uh because
he was a moral philosopher and i'm not
sure politics is a place for philosophy
and i know it's not a place for morality
so that was the big surprise the big
surprise was to find out that
that the moral basis is not just a how
can we get richer how can we keep
inflation down and unemployment down you
know and expand opportunities for
for today's college graduates it wasn't
that it was
it was
a moral book
akron ohio
another fine town
hello mr o'rourke how you doing how are
you doing fine thank you i have a
question regarding peace kills and the
subtitle of the book is america's fun
new imperialism right
well imperialism takes
money and now with the democrats in
control and they have a natural
hostility to imperialism i i quite
frankly as americans we have a natural
hostility towards even the word
imperialism
i wanted to know what you thought of
it of imperialism or even american
expansionism i i i hate that term but
but american foreign policy
is being funded abroad and what the
democrats will do about it if uh if we
want to go into say
even even limited action against a place
like iran
okay this is a a uh uh quite aside from
uh the larger points that you're raising
but obviously very important points
there's a small point to be made here
which is always be careful about the
wise cracks you make and who you make
them to i i give this as a piece of free
advice
uh
the book was called peace kills because
of of a moderate i mean i mean it sounds
like one of those little oxy oxymorons
but the truth of the matter is is that
by pursuing a policy of peace and
toleration you can get 911
just the way same way you can get
yourself killed by by by pursuing a
policy of war that pursuing a policy of
peace for peace sake doesn't necessarily
make you safe
anyway i'm sitting around with my
publisher and he said no we need some
sort of subtitle i mean i'm not quite
getting what this book is about
and i'm yakking away and i said yeah
well you know i mean what it really is
about is america's fun new imperialism
he said that's it
and i said no that's not it
he said yes it is it
anyway the publisher won because i owed
him money and so the subtitle of the
book is america's fun new imperialism
and and and i never meant anything i was
just a wise crack over lunch
okay but now to get on to the more
serious points no of course we don't
want uh uh uh uh imperialism
and um
and unfortunately of course we are going
to have to intervene overseas from time
to time not too often i hope
and the fact that we did it so poorly uh
uh uh in iraq that the outcome has been
so lousy the expense has been so huge
uh and
and the whole thing has been so muddled
is going to make it extremely difficult
to do this again if we really have to in
fact it's probably going to hurt us in
the one place afghanistan where we
probably need to do this much more than
we did
needed to do it in iraq and i say all
this as a supporter
of the war in iraq i thought saddam
hussein was a really bad man a dangerous
man and i i wanted him eliminated
and i'm still not sure it wasn't the
right thing to do but it but it's
obviously pretty clear that
whether it was the right thing to do or
the wrong thing to do we didn't do it
right
in give war a chance you're right
america is the world's policeman all
right a big dumb mick flat foot in the
middle of the one thing cops dread most
a domestic disturbance there you go and
i i guess a lot of
of what i have written about iraq uh was
not too prescient but that was that's
um i i didn't i was not one of those
people who got over there and had a
clear vision of how this was all going
to happen
were there any of those people
maybe there were who knows
but uh
yeah
it really
and and i'm trying to figure out where i
went so wrong on this and and and and
more to the point
where my friend mike kelly to whom this
book is uh to whom peace peace kills is
is dedicated
and um
uh mike was a a uh was the editor of the
atlantic monthly and he was a strong
proponent
of the war in iraq and uh and he went
and he was killed over there he was
killed during the assault in the baghdad
airport mike went as an in bed with the
third infantry he had a very safe in bed
he was back with the general and and ted
koppel and stuff and he worked his way
forward he made friends with people
and he finally worked his way forward to
the point where he became pals with the
guy who's going to lead the armor
assault on the on the baghdad airport
and the guy let him go on on the mission
and he got killed
and mike the last time i saw mikey and i
were in kuwait he was about to go on his
inbed and i'm just hanging out in kuwait
waiting to see what happened
and uh because i didn't want to be
embedded
and mike said you know
six weeks from now i'm gonna be in the
211th latrine cleaning battalion some
place off in the middle of nowhere and
you're going to be driving around
liberating the rock and you're in a car
judging what abaya contest
[Laughter]
he was so wrong
and i thought he was right i thought
that's what was going to happen too
and and mike had been in mike had spent
a lot of time in iraq mike had been in
iraq uh uh uh he during the the kuwait
war the first war the gulf war he had
been he had actually come into kuwait
through iraq he had been there if you
know through all the bombing and stuff
he knew a rock pretty well
and mike thought that that thing was
going to sort itself out and i did too
and obviously so did rumsfeld
i don't blame all those guys for being
wrong i do kind of blame them for
obviously not having a plan b
you know it is kind of their job
orange county california go ahead yes mr
rourke i enjoy your your simplicity and
your insights
i i was involved in prop 13 and out of
that in california and out of that came
economic illiteracy and i kind of coined
it back in the 60s
and out of that came a concept which i
think is most important in the civil
western civilization and that is freedom
uh of my experience that i have a
foundation connected to it out of all
the uh
research done from the highest level
of institutional people professors to
the lowest
99
of the americans cannot
define
freedom
and i wonder if you could just give a
little stab i'd appreciate your
taking that on because you've alluded to
it in some ways already and your most
important word that you came up with and
i wonder if you could give it some time
i think the concept of freedom we're
working on economic literacy right now
which is connected to it
could you give a thumbnail sketch of
what you consider thank you caller
yeah i probably fall into that 99 it's
tough
defining freedom is it really is quite
difficult
i am on the board of advisors
for a group called freedom house it's
been around forever it was founded back
in
1940 41 i should know
by wendell wilkie and and eleanor
roosevelt of all the odd bed fellows and
it was uh an organization that's
original purpose was to
uh to to counteract american
isolationism to get americans uh uh uh
ramped up for the war against
international fascism
and it was then a very important player
in the in the war against international
communism in the cold war
uh it is now uh
an
important player or like that we like to
hope that we're important players
against dictatorships and limitations of
freedom all over the world and we've
been struggling with one of the things
we need as an organization is a tight
coherent definition of freedom
we're an organization for freedom and
democracy well democracy is something so
messy nobody's ever going to come up
with a you know one sentence definition
and so i have been actually been working
on this problem trying to get something
you know that that spells out freedom i
i wish i could do it in seven words i i
think i can do it in a few more than
seven i mean when you're talking about
freedom in us in a society what you are
not talking about is license and anarchy
freedom is not simply doing anything you
damn well please
uh what what freedom is is the broadest
possible
range of of
of individual endeavor that is to say
being allowed to do
uh as you wish in the in in the widest
scope of
from from from from thinking your
religious thoughts right down to making
your living in every way to be to be
given the broadest scope
of personal decision-making
that does not
impinge upon the personal decision
making the freedom
of other people and that of course is
the trick there there is the rub
one of the problems with economic
illiteracy we come back to this zero-sum
thing there are a lot of people out
there maybe even most people in the
world who are under the impression that
if my exercise of freedom leads me to
make a billion dollars that i've somehow
taken that billion or part of that
billion from them
that i have impoverished them by my
getting wealthy
now of course if i've done certain
things like stolen the money that's true
but if i have made the money if i'm bill
gates and i have invented something and
i have man and i've made my billion
dollars and then some
through something that i invented
i have not stolen that money from
anybody i've not made anyone poorer in
fact i've made a lot of people much much
richer by my making that money anyway
that's just one of the problems that the
definition of freedom is
and of course freedom without law
is anarchy and quickly returns to a
matter of force main strength of hand
on the other hand you can have law
we can all be equal before the law
but if that law
is arbitrary you know arbitrary or is i
mean if it's taliban law
we can all be perfectly
equal before the law and have no freedom
whatsoever
so
it's it is i mean it's it's not an easy
problem and it's one that for not not
for purposes of my writing because it's
not never going to be a joke but just
for purposes of my work with freedom
house that i've been wrestling with that
very thing eric and nina flynn email in
we are from toledo and big fans from
your national lampoon days heard you
were coming out with a book about toledo
some time ago is it still in the works
we've enjoyed agreed with your works on
toledo in the past
um yeah i do i had this i had this idea
um to write a a history of toledo ohio
and the reason was not not it's not a
memoir it's not because i'm i'm from
there it's just because
it i wanted to write about a random
place in the united states
and a random place that
wasn't too successful uh but it wasn't a
total failure either you know it's not
east st louis but then again it's not uh
a silicon valley either you know it's
toledo you know it's and um
and i thought what's more random than
where you were born you know you just
picked this thing and plus it turns out
to be and i turn out to be and it's all
kind of average and it's middle america
and so on
and um
i had a little trouble with the idea
because there's a little bit of a one
joke sort of thing i mean because things
toledo is one of those places where
nothing ever quite works out
toledo was going to be
toledo got its start because it was
going to be the the port head port for a
canal
erie canal
brought people from the east coast into
brought goods and serves into the great
lakes and toledo was going to be the the
beginning of the canal running down to
the ohio river that would take things
out of the great lakes
uh the only trouble was that by the time
they actually got the canal dug and
working and it turned out to be
something that was much more expensive
and so on
railroads have been evented
so the canal opened but a little late so
toledo is going to be a railroad center
and so it and they worked very hard at
getting all sorts of railroad operations
but there was a big swamp and there were
certain problems with this plus they
decided to go with light gauge railroad
rather than heavy gauge railroad and but
they finally did get a pretty big nexus
of freight
rail terminals and so on in toledo just
in time for the first metaled road the
first
you know constructed road macadam road
to open between detroit and chicago
so
shortly thereafter they discovered gas
in toledo
natural gas in toledo and they were
under the misapprehension that it was
naturally produced in the earth and
there was an endless supply of it so
they invited various companies such as
the glass making companies to to move to
toledo because they would get free
natural gas
and so
corning and some other glass operations
moved out to toledo and the gas ran out
just immediately there didn't turn out
to be very much gas there at all
right after that toledo became the head
of the the uh became the chief the
center of america's bicycle industry
about two years before the car was
invented and on it goes
this is great this is like america you
know and yet you can't do a whole book
this is you know it's just that so i
came a cropper and then 9 11 happened
this is idea that i had conceived in the
late 90s and and and i was working on in
2000 2001
and it all had to do with this kind of
introspective nature america was things
were going very well in america so well
that we could take all that time out for
the clinton thing if you remember that
thing you did with the you know
stuff we can't say on family tv
or you know and americans were in kind
of an introspective mood you know
where'd we come from what made america
the wonderful nutty place that it is and
then
yeah the outside world intruded
on september 11th and so i kind of put
this project aside but it's something i
want to come back to and and writing
about adam smith
has helped me figure out how to do it in
an odd sort of way because i i've begun
to realize just how important an
industrial center like toledo even one
that never really quite took fire how
important these places are and also how
important failure is to success
capitalism creative destruction
trump trump tier
i'm saying his name right
chesapeake virginia you're on with p.j
o'rourke thanks for holding oh well
happy too um and perhaps i should always
say thanks for c-span
and let me say that i've had the
experience i've had a few other times
over the years on whole discovering
there's
several things i'd like to say about
what i've heard while i've been
listening on hold
but the question i started with uh
dj said a little while ago that
despite his
long friendship with a hunter thompson
that in the end hunter really hadn't
anything
as an alternative to offer no positive
statement to go with his absurd and very
entertaining uh criticism and i guess
what i would say in response to an even
earlier comment that pj made about uh
you were called in with a number of
specific complaints to which uh his
response was i don't see why he's angry
at me
uh
i guess i would say what i've found over
the years with cj distinction both very
entertaining and
more than a few times maddening
is that
i almost always agree with the
skepticism i very often don't agree with
his judgments
uh he has a tendency and perhaps is just
a nature of humor to rather
snorkelly and often with
hilarious effect
dismiss people who are in their plotting
way trying to offer in action
alternatives
true enough yeah i mean you you pegged
me directly for for a conservative uh
and i am one um uh to go back to hunter
thompson for a moment i want to make it
clear that that was in no way a
criticism of hunter's writing from me uh
it was a a criticism or not even a
criticism it was an observation about a
sort of quandary he found himself in
and a quandary caused more in some ways
by his fans than his i mean i consider
hunter to be the brilliant absurdist of
the 20th century he is the guy that took
the idea of waiting for godot a play
that i think just stinks and actually
made it hilarious you know people say oh
you know waiting for godot is very funny
no it's not i'm sorry i've sat through
good productions of it and bad
productions of it and i've heard a few
self-satisfied snickers from the you
know the the hepa members of the
audience but it's not funny it's not
funny at all hunter is funny fear and
loathing in las vegas covers the same
ground as waiting for godot and it's
hilarious so
anyway but on to
to uh my tendency to be snarky
towards liberals uh i am pretty
skeptical of people who want to make the
world better um
not because i uh impugn their motives uh
uh or think that they're bad people it's
just that i don't know you know it seems
like an awful lot of the bad trouble
that we've gotten into over the
centuries
millennia really has come from people
who wanted to make the world better
people who want to make the world worse
of course are a big problem too uh but
you kill them and they go away uh uh
more people have died from the world
bettering ideas of karl marx than
than died from attila the hun you know
let's not forget that fascism had its
world-bettering side too there were
actually hard to imagine but there were
fascist idealists ezra pound i give you
as profound
i i fear
uh
uh
uh world savers and and and i i i i like
any good conservative i fear change like
any 60 year old guy i fear change
and i tend to fall back on the way
things have always been done
fully knowing that a lot of evil has
always been done too there must have
been people you know i suppose 200 years
ago who were saying well slavery is a
very bad thing but it's always existed
it's in the old testament and stuff
and of course they were wrong now that
was the the the abolitionists were right
uh uh
people who want to better the world uh
uh uh are right sometimes
but doesn't keep me from being scared
about big
reform
plans big big plans to to change things
like most conservatives i tend to give a
vote to the dead
north andover massachusetts go ahead
wow
how do i follow that
i couldn't i mean the gentleman who
was uh preceding me was perfect i mean
you give you you give so many ideas to a
person who's listening to you that you
forget what you called for when you've
been home that's the danger of being on
hold isn't it yeah i've been through
this you know but by the time you get
off hold you for a forgotten why you
were on hold and second place you've
thought of all these other things seven
different things to talk about well
first of all i'm from buffalo so you
have a
beautiful connection with the erie canal
yes buffalo we think of buffalo as
toledo east exactly right exactly right
it is in such disarray now i'm now from
massachusetts north andover
massachusetts which is a few few miles
south of your state
i know i know right where it is
absolutely so i have i feel like you're
a neighbor yeah we practically are yeah
i'm a writer i'm a poet and when you
said you don't like to write at first i
thought oh my that's abhorrent
but now i understand because you
do it to put bread on the table
that's the truth and if you're writing
it because you have such joy you said
you were a your closet poet when you
were younger
or tried to be a poet when you were
younger
i believe that every written piece that
is written well is poetry prose poetry
or
um you know lyric or whatever
but the other things that i wanted to
ask you when you said writers
reporters do not
uh go deeply because you can't
do you see that hunters and gatherers
are two groups in the world
and grazers
might be the third which
hmm
yes well actually i always i have a
tendency to divide people into uh into
farmers and hunters
uh and it it's sort of the the the
settled civilized farmer
and the
and the hunter that descends you know
like
like the wolf on the sheep and the fold
and so
and and and
both in personality types and um but to
get back to something
that the caller said earlier um
there is a joy in creating things and
i don't have it
i mean i have much more joy down the
basement building birdhouses uh uh
with my very primitive carpentry skills
uh than i have about writing and and and
the caller was exactly right about why
uh uh this is a job i do it's a craft
it's not an art
um uh i'm not um fulfilling some sense
of
of of inner
i don't know what
um i i i feel more artistically
fulfilled
by building shelves in the garage
rather uneven and wobbly shelves i may
say but nonetheless shelves in the
garage i stand back and i look at those
and i can i can just you know fill
myself with glee and have a beer and
think what i've accomplished and stuff
much more than i do
uh
being a reporter
we have little less than an hour left on
in-depth today with pj o'rourke and we
will be right back with your phone calls
and emails
talk to our guest
p.j o'rourke has collected art from his
travels and here's some of it
all the time that i've done
overseas reporting
i've always brought back
interesting things or what things that
seemed interesting
at the time sometimes you get them back
and they aren't interesting at all
and um and my wife is it's something of
the same i mean she has uh i think she's
a bit of a frustrated uh uh visual
artist herself
and uh and both of us are very
interested in art and very interested in
design we don't know anything about it
but
we we have fun with it and so quite a
few of the things around here are are
are souvenirs from from trips
uh these little santos um are from uh
from paraguay
and paraguay has got this uh a very
interesting subculture to it a paraguay
is a seems perfectly um
a spanish latin american
but practically everyone in paraguay is
partly or wholly guarani indian
and speaks guarani at home and the
guarani indians had a remarkably vivid
tradition
a really skilled tradition of wood
carving so you go in these very ordinary
churches in
in paraguay and the interior will be
carved and painted to a fairly well
and a little
manifestation of that are these these
these
little saints
why were you in paraguay oh uh let's see
uh they threw out their dictator i don't
know this was back in the i don't even
quite remember i was back in back in the
80s they threw out their dictator and
they were fighting with each other and
you know that's my job go cover trouble
bunnies you know when they were ever
although i found that paraguay actually
wasn't a very troubled place
um
modern art from romania
uh walking down the street in romania
saw an art gallery
and um i just
liked it and so ended up bringing back
that from romania again
the person in the gallery was romanian
and told me all about the artist
unfortunately she told me about the
artist in romanian
so therefore i know nothing it's
um
cuba cloth uh i brought that back from
tanzania though it's not actually from
tanzania i think it's from um
eastern
congo
but i'm not absolutely certain because
again it was explained to me in a
foreign language
i'm like a really lousy connoisseur
this was
due to drink
i was in macedonia
and i i had dined
perhaps
too deeply and too well
and was taking a little constitutional
because the room was spinning slightly
on my way back to hotel and i walked
back by an art gallery which was open
late at night and there was this amazing
dead fish in the window
and
i love paintings because you can roll
them up uh
and stick them in your luggage when i
unrolled that there was some
consternation in the house but we've
kind of fallen in love with it since
this is actually a well-known guy from
brazil i was down in uh in in rio for
the uh the ecological summit uh uh back
in the 90s
and um
this is a guy named platero or that's
the name he's taken and he is as his
name would indicate primarily a potter
but carrying pottery around is is a
dicey matter but i love this painting
and this has been a huge hit with all
three of our kids they all go through a
stage at about
about three
where they're just fascinated by this
um
by this painting
this uh
was uh some
store that used to be over in union
station that stole sold
malaysian cha-chas chuchkas
it's in
um saw it and brought it home
on the other hand all the haitian art is
indeed from haiti where i've done a
couple of times
and um
i was trying to find things that uh
that adequately expressed uh how weird
haiti is uh that does not the one here
you're looking at right now this is
haiti as the haitians would like to see
haiti
directly below it is haiti as it
actually looks note the ecological
devastation and the dead trees
the trees are not dead because something
bad has happened to the atmosphere or
global warming or anything they're dead
because
people keep chopping their limbs off for
firewood
and and even though they value the tree
they'll be so desperate for firewood
they'll chop one limb off it and
eventually the trees just get like that
what about those rabbits up there boy i
have no idea you know crazy yes
something strange is going on in the
rabbit picture and i'm not sure i want
to know this is interesting you don't
see many the one on the left you don't
see many um
local representations of street crime in
their own country i mean usually it's
beautiful hills and beautiful trees and
and frolicking natives and this is
somebody getting shot right on the
street which of course happens in haiti
entirely too often
i i brought this mask back from west
africa just because
i like the way that it looked but i was
in this store with a lot of masks and
and so and i was trying to um
to to to figure out what the masks
represented there you know so that i
would have some story for moments like
this to tell about the mask
and i i don't know this mask didn't seem
to have any particular purpose at all
except to be a mask to look nice but
there was another mask that i saw
and it was a very interesting mask it
was almost like a little too interesting
and
i i asked the young lady in the store
i said what what's what's this mask for
and she blushed a lot and she was it was
interesting i guess i never really
thought about she was very dark skinned
and i didn't really realize that people
who were that dark skin could blush that
vividly but i mean she turned quite red
and
uh
and she stammered and i mean her english
was perfectly good and she said and
finally she said
dancing at night
moving right along
here we have the handsome antelope masks
which represent the antelope
yeah
welcome back to in-depth our guest today
is pj o'rourke author of 12 books the
most recent pj o'rourke on the wealth of
nations a look at adam smith this is the
cover it comes out uh right now this
month i think i think yes i think we're
sitting right upon the uh publication
date or something like that we have a
little over an hour left we'll put the
phone numbers up on the screen in case
you'd like to participate and the email
address booktv cspan.org
lots of emails have come in p j o'rourke
while in college this is from don
traeger in madison wisconsin while in
college at the university of wisconsin
in the 70s i had a subscription to
lampoon i had two roommates when it came
out we'd laugh out loud our favorite two
issues were the ones with the texans at
the alamo raising their arms in the air
to surrender and the other one was the
dog on the cover with a pistol to its
head buy this magazine or we'll shoot
this dog
could you please say a few words about
doug kenny who wrote so much for that
magazine also did doug kill himself i
believe he fell off a cliff and died but
never knew if he jumped or just fell
doug was uh
no i don't believe that doug
uh uh uh did kill himself doug was
he he he loved
sort of
he was one of those brave but clumsy
people
it'd be just like him to
fall off a cliff i'm afraid
um he was the person i was closest to at
at the national land lampoon he was the
guy that pretty much brought me in there
and uh
and he was one of the three guys that
founded it he just couldn't have been a
nicer guy and he was absolutely
hilarious he was just one of those
people who had uh
um
i know how to to write certain things in
a funny way
but but i'm not
personally a comic person i'm not that
funny to be around uh
i've spent a lot of time with dave berry
dave berry is funny all the time
being with dave barrett is like reading
a dave berry piece
uh being with me is a little like
reading uh adam smith not my book on
that smith but smith's book on adam so
on the wealth of nations
uh i just not
and doug was
a lot of fun
um
but he was sort of tortured by i don't
know um
i think one of the problems with people
who have a knack for comedy is they
don't feel it's important
and they want to do something
that is somehow more important
and
since i never thought that i would do
anything at all i'm satisfied with doing
something unimportant
doesn't bother me
but every now and then i find myself
such as writing about adam smith
maybe this is creeping up on me and i do
want to do something important
ventura california you're on with pj
o'rourke go ahead
thank you uh i want to say how much i
enjoy booktube ventura california works
books
speak up there
listen i was a student at the university
of california in berkeley from 1963
to 1971 so i saw
why and i did turn into a very staunch
republican i can't hear him
ventura if you can hang on just a second
you got your volume control d here
go ahead and speak ventura let's see if
we can try again would you venture
i was a student at the university of
california at berkeley in 19 from 1963
to 1971 and became a staunch
conservative wait a minute 63 to 71. oh
you were having fun
it was only a four-year program
well i got three degrees there so i
didn't entirely waste my time maybe in
law school but other than that
and i became a staunch republican due to
lyndon johnson and due to the excesses
of berkeley
and i have an overpowering feeling now
that the conservative cause that i have
enjoyed and worked in uh for
these number of years has absolutely
peaked and it is downhill from now on do
you have that feeling
boy i fear you're right yeah i certainly
do i mean in in the watches of the night
as they say it does make my blood run
cold a bit
of course you know taking the long view
this stuff tends to be cyclical in
american society
bad is i think the situation is for
conservativism at the moment it isn't as
bad as it was in 1932 for instance and
that that was indeed a long long
recovery or you remember i mean you are
you're of an age uh uh you like uh like
me you can remember when goldwater lost
in 64. who
house wipeout time
um so we've been through this before
my concern is not so much that
that that we're in a cycle where
conservatism is not so popular and the
principles of conservatism are not so
popular i'm i'm concerned about the
conservatives themselves i think that
american conservatives have lost their
bearings to a certain extent uh being a
a political conservative in the american
tradition which is really being
something that the the the that the
brits would call a a wig in a way it's
not tory it's a it's a it's it's a wig
sensibility
um is it it is not a about isolationism
it is not a a a about a small tent
it's not about religious exclusivism
it's not about
reintroducing religion uh
into politics i mean
i i like to think of myself as a
reasonably religious person i do my best
as i can but you know when i start
talking to people about god's role in
politics
i think this you know i think
oh look at politics look at politics in
america look at politics around the
world look at politics
all through history
does it look like god's been involved in
this no when it comes to involvement
with politics that's the other guy
that's involved in politics you know not
not not god
so i just i don't like where the
american conservative movement is headed
i don't like this anti-immigrant stuff
well i'm not a cheyenne i'm not a sioux
you know i mean where'd i come from you
know i mean i snuck across the border
you know just like guys are doing today
down in el paso
and uh well not me personally but by
immediate you know forbearers
and so i i i worry about the soul of
conservatism itself not so much about
the american political cycle being
yeah american political cycle is not
doing us any favors at the moment who do
you think are the funniest conservative
public figures that is which
conservatives are the most genuinely
witty and which ones are the most
completely ridiculous that's david
seidman i see yes he is making the
distinction between intentionally funny
and unintentionally funny
um i like the guys over at the america
at the uh
at the weekly standard i think the guys
the weekly standard have a very good
sense of humor um phil a a terzian who's
the literary editor he writes that
parody on the last page a lot of people
don't realize that phil you're busted
that's the formerly with the providence
journalist exactly yeah andy ferguson is
a very matt labash is very funny richard
starr who uh
again i'm busting him i he's responsible
for a lot of the diary entries up front
what about bill crystal well well
bill's bill is bill's very funny in
meetings his writing neither he nor fred
specialize in in in in funny writing
although they do both have pretty good
sense of humor privately
ridiculous as a another matter
you know
i just i i have trouble with the whole
christian right you know and not because
i'm not a christian and not because i'm
not a writer you know but it just yeah
i just have trouble you know and um
god talks to me about a lot of things
but not politics he just
craig arkansas you're on with pj
o'rourke go ahead
uh good morning mr o'rourke hi
uh i'm of your generation i'm 60. there
you go
i have a dream of writing a book i'm
going to call it button down blue collar
there you go yeah
i know exactly what you mean too yeah
yeah well anyways i've got it i've got
three degrees but i'm an electrician
well anyways that's great because that
means that you have gone through the
entire college education and decided to
do something useful anyway
anyways i
graduated from university of arkansas in
69 lived
through the vietnam war served five
years in the army
i was fortunate enough to do my short
term in thailand so i never heard a shot
fired in anger
but i did sit on four hundred thousand
long tons of bombs wow
anyways uh
my daughter is currently in iraq flying
blackhawks in blood well bless her soul
that's great good for her anyways i i
live day to day looking for proof of
life with an email oh yeah i know god
that's that's got to be
real scary
anyways here i want you know i'm furious
at the government
vis-a-vis vietnam korea and iraq it
seems to me like for some reason or
another the politicians in congress and
our presidential leadership are more
than happy
to put our soldiers
in harm's way and are not willing to
commit the country
to
what i would say if we're going to
commit our men to a war
or some kind of conflict we should be
willing to commit them to something that
is
a value that we would commit everything
and go all the way to win that war i.e
if i was running the uh if i was
president and felt that we needed to be
in vietnam
i would have put
our armies on the on the dmz and gone
north
to hanoi and and china wanted to get
involved so be it this is this is
you know
uh national survival
i got to say uh uh uh you know you're
you're
you're talking right to me i mean
the um
war is a awful business it's an
incredibly dangerous business and it
shouldn't be undertaken lightly and one
part about not undertaking it lightly is
you do not go to war
without a plan of winning i mean how
insane is that that is like walking into
a biker bar you know uh when you're you
know i say a 165 pound wimp like me you
know and and
and start you know shouting your your
your poor opinion of of uh motorcycles
in general and the hell's angels
specifically i mean
you do not but this is like
not even me doing this this is like me
sending somebody to do this you do not
send troops into war
without a way for them to win that war
without a clear mission for them to
accomplish
it is just
wrong it's just simply wrong
this is a problem i have with iraq again
i say i supported the war in iraq in
fact i still support the war in iraq but
what i
infuriates me is there
because the the the initial
uh military operation in iraq did not
result in in
in the situation that we wanted
why wasn't there some other plan to do
something else uh the night before i
left for kuwait to to to go cover the
war i was talking to a friend of mine at
abc news
and he and i said we almost said this to
each other simultaneously we were
standing there saying we talked about
the war and about whether this was the
right thing to do and the right time to
do it and the right way to do it and all
that and we said to each other don't you
hope that this is being planned by
somebody who is smarter than we are
well apparently not you know and i just
you know really it hurts me a lot uh to
see people sent into into harm's way
uh without without a purpose and
and a goal
and and a clear strategy and and various
backup strategies uh it just strikes me
as being just just just arrogant
uh a way to proceed
and i'm worried
that the democrats are going to be no
better about this than
than the republicans a whole lot of
people have been killed because the
republicans invaded
how many people will be killed because
the democrats retreat
they don't seem to have a plan either
several emails about your writing what
you've written and done
when you spoke at the university of
kentucky back in the late 80s you
imitated a whistle that a parakeet in
lebanon the country not
the city in south central kentucky made
before a bomb was about to hit in its
neighborhood
any chance you could imitate that for us
this afternoon
that's from dwayne bonifer of ebenezer
kentucky
at the commodore hotel in beirut there
was a parrot in a cage out by the pool
and what that parrot could do was a
perfect
imitation of an incoming artillery shell
which i'm not going to try and and
imitate on television because i don't
know what it's going to do to the sound
equipment here and i'm not sure my
imitation was all that good anyway but
the thing is that parrot had great
timing
it would wait until things have been
quiet for a couple of days and people
were out around the pool and it would
wait until about six seven in the
evening when everybody had a few drinks
or more than a few drinks and then it
would do this imitation of an incoming
artillery shot everybody would hit the
deck and run inside and dive in the pool
you know it would just be the stupid
parrot
have you returned to the summerland
hotel since you wrote about it in
holidays in hell can you give us an
update
where would you go to write a 21st
century update of that book thanks for
all the laughs fran and phil peterson
houston texas
well i have not been back to the
summerland hotel since which is where uh
summerland hotels on a southern uh uh
side of beirut's in in a shiite area
there it's one of the areas that the
israelis have bombed
although i don't think they bombed the
summerland in particular
it was the best operating hotel at the
time that the twa hostages were
kidnapped in um
was that was
1985
85 is i'm pretty sure was a5 and um
after the hostages were released
amazing story
i i just flew that i was in italy
and i and when the hostages were taken
in beirut i flew to beirut
and i and i went to the summerland hotel
which is where the people that i knew
that were covering this story happened
to be staying and i'm there the first
night i'm up with because i
knew a bunch of people from abc and i
happened to be up in the abc
sort of headquarters there they'd taken
over a couple hotel rooms and this
friend of mine derwin johnson was a
producer at abc derwent goes out on the
on the balcony to get a breath of fresh
air because derwent doesn't smoke and
everybody else in there does you know
he goes out for the opposite reason that
people now go out on balconies
and darwin comes back and his eyes are
as big as pie plates i mean just
creep it and we go through one drew
he said the hostages
are here
and we rush out on the balcony and the
kidnappers had brought the hostages the
twa hostages to the summerland hotel for
dinner
and we ran downstairs and talked of
course they're just scared to death they
don't know what is going on we don't
quite know what's going on but but
apparently one group had grabbed them
from another group and this group was
actually trying to protect them from the
worst uh on it went but the kidnappings
of journalists had started then terry
anderson had been kidnapped and several
other people
and um when the hostages were released
we all got out of lebanon immediately
because it was i mean journalists don't
mind getting shot at
too much because a
we can dock we're not soldiers we don't
have to shoot back we can hide behind
stuff
and also because uh
a lot of these people
aren't that good a shot
i remember being at the at the at the
the uh georges uh uh uh
hotel in uh uh what was left of it on
the on the carnation in lebanon and
during the civil war in 84
and people were water skiing and there's
like automatic weapons fire going on and
i said to the bartender because the bar
was about all that was left the hotel
was burned out and i said the bartender
i said aren't they a little uh worried
about the
water skiing while there's sniper fire
going is it he said oh i said it's
automatic weapons they're not accurate
at all
but kidnapping's another matter getting
kidnapped and held
for who knows how long and of course
nowadays getting tortured and then your
head cut off
just really takes all the appeal out of
the adventure doesn't
daniel pinchuk in any event in your
opinion what are the funniest pieces
you've ever written
oh man
the funniest piece i ever wrote i'm not
sure i can see it on the air
how's there
we have a beeper delay don't you have
little children watching this
yeah
there's no beeper delay
um yeah no
okay
we're gonna leave you with a guess
captain jeff husted of mount pleasant
south carolina
i was exposed to my first taste of gonzo
journalism in an episode of rolling
stone the story was written by a
hysterical author who vividly described
inhaling nitrous oxide and turning loose
and apparently rabid dog do you remember
that story and do you miss that author
it seems that swinging to the extreme
right is the death of a sense of humor
just ask dennis miller
hmm i didn't know dennis miller swung to
the extreme right but i believe that now
incidentally the the emailer is not
speaking of a story of mine
don't have a vicious dog i have a
black lab who's
you might lick you to death
wouldn't know where to get the nitrous
oxide it's got to be hunter thompson
that he's talking about
um i don't know about swinging to the
extreme right being the death of a sense
of humor evelyn wah
one of the funniest writers on the face
of the earth he started out pretty far
right and stayed over there
saki h.h monroe uh a british short story
writer another one of the great funny
writers on earth
no liberal he
i would say that uh this uh is uh a
sense a sense of the absurd is not a
respecter of politics it happens to pop
up
paul krasner couldn't have been more
left-wing and he was pretty funny will
cinda of new orleans seeing you on tv
over the years it seems that to me that
you are the most animated and jovial
when discussing h.l mencken can you
describe your current feeling about him
i love him
yeah angel menken is really i mean h.l
macon was the model of a crabby guy and
i mean he made i mean he just he just he
had so much fun being so crabby and he
was so crabby for so long about so many
things it was just uh
very refreshing you know and especially
as i get older and more crabby uh uh you
know he's he also
uh uh something that that is not
remembered
as well these days about h l mankind and
and bears mentioning
is that uh he was the author of a really
worthwhile memoir i hate the memoir form
i really wish it would go away it's
right down there with blogging as far as
i'm concerned you know it's like
what i did last summer you know
for grownups
and i could care less
h.l menken wrote a charming three volume
memoir
heathen days newspaper days and i forget
what the third one's called but anyway
especially heathen days about his
childhood in baltimore it is just
brilliant and it's a model of its kind
and
incidentally it doesn't appear it
doesn't apparently it's not all that
factual but it's it's a bonus
richmond virginia you're on with pj
o'rourke go ahead
yes you mentioned that you have visited
70 countries and i was wondering
what culture do you think would seem
most alien to americans
i would say france
france is the most alien culture
to americans as far as i can tell
i you know
i i have never been to a country
where i didn't enjoy myself i mean there
may have been aspects of it that i
wasn't too happy with but i have been
very happy and for the most part very
comfortable
in most
cultures most countries and i would say
the exception is paris during tourist
season paris in august i've had the
misfortune of being in paris songs where
i have been treated incredibly rudely
grossly overcharged
where what little french i have has been
mercilessly made fun of uh
yeah
france that's the answer miami good
morning good afternoon good afternoon i
wanted to ask mr o'rourke
what does he think about the mindset
of the colonialists
and how does he think he plays a part
in say american policy
in iraq worldwide and and does he think
or
do you think that the arrogance of the
the people who planned the war and
forgot to plan the peace
do you think that they had a possible
mindset
colonial mindset by ignoring the
majority of iraqis who live
in america for advice or for some kind
of um
some kind of hint of what to do in the
country after they
and they marched in
that's a really good point the last bit
your point about the arrogance that uh
uh that the american planners have not
consulting the iraqis and i know where
they live i'm from toledo ohio i mean
toledo dearborn
detroit that area has got the largest
concentration of arab americans in
america
and as a matter of fact as you drive
into toledo from the east
through all these corn fields this dead
flat ohio you know this this this grant
wood middle middle west
the first thing you see as you approach
toledo is a great big beautiful white
mosque
in perrysburg ohio
and uh and a cool building it is and
very nice people there i i i went to a
reconciliation ceremony there
aft after 9 11. that was terribly
arrogant colonialism is a little
trickier i mean colonialism is one of
these words we've made it too big the
way we've made feudalism and fascism too
big colonialism has a strict definition
and it's
it is what we did when we moved here
as europeans in in in the in the 17th
and 18th century colonialism is about
going someplace moving in
taking over the land building a family
staying there forever
uh
what what we have been up to you you
might say that
we've been exercising some imperialism
but ain't none of us that want to move
to iraq so it's not not colonialism
per se
now is there a colonial aspect to taking
over the oil now that is an interesting
question a lot of people
say look this war was just about oil i
just wanted to tell a quick story about
that because i feel like i had an
epiphany about that i'm over in kuwait
i'm waiting for the war to start and i'm
hanging around with some with some air
force guys and uh we're
flying around in in chinook helicopters
they're taking me around uh these places
and
i love the hulk i love helicopters
i love big machinery uh
family was in the car business and i
just love machinery so we're flying
around the in the chinooks and
and we're flying over kuwait and quaint
is the size of it looks tiny on the map
but it's the size of connecticut and
rhode island put together it's flat as a
patio and we're flying over the top of
it and it was just
wall to wall military equipment i mean
there is just
everything down there there are a whole
bunch more helicopters and there are
airplanes and patriot missile batteries
and artillery and tanker trucks and 160
000 american troops and all these other
camps it's like
wall-to-wall war it's war out to the
curvature of the horizon 360 degrees of
war and i'm up in this chinook i'm
looking at this and i just had this like
thought i said
boy is it more expensive to steal oil
than it is to buy it
i mean oil would really have to go
up to about a thousand dollars a barrel
before we got a good deal on what we did
in iraq
next call for pj o'rourke orlando
florida
yes mr o'rourke i have a comment
followed by a question
you said that you support the war in
iraq i don't know if you've read the
entire transcripts of the downing street
memos but i have a copy of the full
report printed in the new york times
last year very specifically it shows
that president bush prior to the war was
willing to do anything to get us into
iraq
yeah uh i i shouldn't doubt it uh but
that
isn't why i support the war in iraq it's
not because i love president bush i
don't particularly
my feeling about the war in iraq was
this i was in kuwait uh uh uh during the
the in the aftermath of the of the first
gulf war actually wasn't even the
aftermath i got in uh uh through a fluke
a mistake i i i got into kuwait before
the allied troops did i was in a little
convoy of reporters and aid workers
and we accidentally drove in the middle
of the night drove through the front
lines and and we wound up in kuwait
fortunately the iraqis had left or we
would have been toast
uh but so i was i saw what the iraqis
did in kuwait it was hideous it was
hideous i talked to the people that were
tortured i saw the graves of the people
that were killed i saw the utter
devastation of kuwait city by the iraqis
so right iraqis
that was not a good government and then
i i i had friends that were covering the
the the shiites and the kurds when they
were slaughtered by sodom hussein and my
feeling was simply this
is saddam hussein a bad man
is he running
a country that does bad things is this
country going to do more bad things does
it have the oil money to do the bad
things with
okay if those are the questions is the
answer better cooperation with france no
i mean so i was i was in favor of the
war that doesn't
keep me from being a strong critic of
of what has happened in in the wake of
the war and maybe wiser heads should i
mean i'm no genius maybe wiser head
should have prevailed maybe we should
have waited maybe we should have used
sanctions maybe we should have taken
some other approach
above my pay grade as they say
the author of 12 books currently pj
o'rourke is the h.l mencken research
fellow at the cato institute a
correspondent for the atlantic monthly
and a contributing editor at the weekly
standard larry tremblay of charlotte
north carolina emails in as a new
hampshire resident are you aware of the
free state movement i am aware of the
free state movement of trying to get a
whole
bunch of libertarians to to to move to
new hampshire
to take over the state
i just want to say those libertarians
it's very unlibertarian move to try and
take over a state you know
we usually go up there and just mind
your own business and ignore everybody
and you know i've lived up there for a
long time and new hampshire new
hampshire people are
quite good at ignoring you and
they're even pretty good at minding
their own business so just come up move
to new hampshire and enjoy our low tax
rate and
you know when it comes to town meeting
and state legislature and stuff do what
the rest of us real new hampshire writes
do and don't go
judy rogers marietta georgia i would
just like to know what the initials pjs
stand for
what embarrassing name is he hiding
that is pretty embarrassing it's patrick
it's patrick o'rourke which is one of
those names is just like so epic patrick
jake o'rourke in fairness jake was my
granddad
um but patrick o'rourke is just so i
mean it's just so ethnic and i'm only a
quarter irish you know and i
my father was clifford
and uh my mother you thought that that
was kind of a silly my mother i don't
think had ever met an irishman before
and she thought that that was kind of
wasn't an irish enough so she used to
call him patrick and when i was named
uh uh when i was born i was named
patrick so
17 years of school or however many it
was that i went may have been more and
it's done you know depending on how many
times i flunked
never got through
roll call at the beginning of the year
not once from kindergarten through
graduate school without the teachers
saying ah hungarian huh
polish
or some other such uh
a a joke about and so um
as soon as i i could i i shed the
patrick and i i used to sign myself pj
and i never really thought about it i
just i just thought it looked
cooler as a signature p period j period
over
and it wasn't until i've been writing
for a while and i met some people who
had written or written who had read what
i'd written
but had never met me and they said
oh you're p.j o'rourke and i thought oh
pajamas i and i'll never be rid of it
you know so
there you go do your friends call you pj
yeah yeah and your wife
yeah
what should i do chicago
uh yes um
mr o'rourke was talking earlier about uh
how he didn't believe that god played a
role in politics and in proverbs 16 12
it says this is an abomination for king
to commit wickedness
for a throne is established by
righteousness
and i just wanted to know what he
thought about that and also if he could
talk about the uh
the bush tax cuts and what uh says the
democrats are in control of congress
what
deal he thinks the republicans can get
from them in terms of all the taxes
being repealed some of them are none of
them thank you caller
taxes will be right back up with the
democrats in charge
and and bush looking for for you know to
deal with them on other issues he's
probably not going to veto it so it's
going to be expensive oh i think god has
a role in politics his role is to send a
whole lot of politicians to hell um
you know it's all in due time uh i don't
think on the other hand that he's down
in the local polling place
rick robinson
rick robinson is it great
from from kentucky
robinson we're talking about you tell me
while riding parliament of horrors pj
worked in our office to see what it was
like on capitol hill this is god's own
truth we referred to him as our aarp
intern
at 60 you now have your chance at that
job in any event cato just published an
article stating that libertarians should
look to the democrats as opposed to the
gop in the next election any thoughts
they're
wrong know
rick i i think i might be slightly
responsible for that too because
i was talking to the guys over at cato
and i was saying you know for years now
for understandable reasons for for a
dozen years now
you have depended at cato for your
policy influence on
basically on republican staffers on on
on influencing republican staffers cato
a libertarianist has always been very
careful to be nonpartisan and it's
hardly complementary of republicans in
general but nonetheless it's republican
staffers have kind of carried the
freight and i said you know
a whole new group of staffers and
and you should be looking
to get some of your ideas at least
partly implanted in some democratic
staffers so i don't know about looking
to the democrats in general but
i've been urging cato for a while to do
something that uh is kind of a series of
reports and
compilations of research what i call the
war on the poor
and what that
is in my mind is is
all the government regulation government
interference and government tax policy
and stuff
that that adversely affect lower income
uh uh americans if not lower income
people all around the world and i think
there's quite a body of government
policy that does that
tampa florida go ahead hi my name is
john connoyer um first i read your books
when i was around 1516 and you
definitely were a major influence on my
political outlook on becoming a
libertarian or calling myself a
libertarian
and i must admit i am completely baffled
by your continuous support of the right
now that
it has turned into a religious right and
one of its poses is an anti-gay part
anyway it's not my question i just want
to get that out there my question is
what can we do to get a
libertarian party that can actually be a
valid choice
uh compared to the democratic and
republican parties
you know i just think we're we're just
darn out of luck in this respect uh
and one of the problems with
libertarianism as a political party is
that libertarianism is really
a way of of measuring and gauging
uh to to what extent
government activity interferes with
individual liberty and individual
responsibility always important side of
liberal you know people think
libertarianism means oh i can do
anything i want you know that's not what
it's about it means individual uh uh
liberty but it also means individual
responsibility the libertarian
philosophy is not really a political
philosophy it's really a a a philosophy
of freedom and a way of measuring how
political systems deliver upon that
freedom and responsibility or how they
impinge upon the freedom and
responsibility a libertarian political
party would essentially be a party where
you would stand on the stump and say
americans i can do less for you in fact
i can do nothing for you you've got to
do it for yourself it's going to be very
hard to get elected
why do i stick with the republicans even
though in certain respects they stink i
don't we didn't mention a gay thing
before i find that deeply offensive i
just don't think you know
nothing we know about politicians and
what they do in the bedroom gives us any
reason to think they should have any
control over what anybody else does in
the bedroom it would be bad
and i don't like the
uh religious intrusion uh and it's not
just born-again christians it's i don't
like any religious intrusion i don't
care for it with uh uh uh with uh
islamic extremists uh i wouldn't care
for it uh uh back when the catholic
church did it uh pre-reformation times i
don't care for it with cromwell et
cetera
um i stick with them because america
doesn't really have political parties in
the sense that european countries have
political parties you can't be thrown
out of an american political party you
don't carry a card
you can't be purged
neither of our parties represent
are ideological they don't have a core
ideology it's a general tendency
the general tendency of the republicans
is towards less government and less
taxation
not that they're doing very well is that
and the general tendency of the of the
democrats is towards more regulation and
a greater redistribution of wealth and
actually not doing all that well at that
either which is as far as i'm concerned
a good thing huge overlap between these
two things some brit once said that
america is a single party state and just
like americans they've got two of them
you know and there is something to that
years ago i was in russia back when
russia was russia back in the old soviet
union days and i'd gotten to be friends
with this guy
or you know you know close drinking
acquaintances at any rate and one night
when he felt he finally could trust me
and we'd had a lot to drink he leaned
over and he said you say you're
republican i said yes he said are you
party member
well i sent him 30 bucks i guess i am
you know
there's really you know we just don't
have political parties like that so i
support the republicans you know partly
because
their tendencies are a little better
than democrats partly because i was born
juan i was just born a republican my
grandmother was very very
republican her father my
great-grandfather had
been a county sheriff in downstate
illinois very active in in in in
republican uh parties as his father had
been and one day when i was a kid i got
up the nerve to ask my grandmother i
said grandma
um
what's the difference between
republicans and democrats it was like
long icy silence and she looked at me
and she said
democrats rent
and that was it
in give war a chance which you wrote in
the early 90s you have a partial enemies
list fun list
but
you list
12 or so members of congress 10 or so
members of congress
eight of those 10 are still in congress
senators harken kennedy kerry dodd
representative stark uh barbara boxer
now in the senate ed markey barbara
mikulski do we have a permanent
political class in this country oh yes
we do and we can thank our lucky stars
that we do because
i if we didn't have a permanent
political class these people would be
out
in the private sector really screwing
things up you know i i have this
argument with ed crane over at cato all
the time that's a big
term limits guy and i said ed
do you want a dog who knows where the
bones are buried or do you want a dog
that'll dig up the whole yard
silver spring maryland go ahead yes my
name is john mcmillan and my question is
when you defined
subculture you used
uh appalachian white i wonder if you'd
been speaking to
a non-mixed audience say in private
circles would you would your inferior
culture have been
maybe uh
blacks as blacks in this country today
or
the other question is
why has this country failed to
deal with
the schools public schools
and and deep-seated violence in this
country as though these people were just
regular americans and they need this
problem solved i don't think
well let's see the first part of that
question no i wouldn't have used blacks
as an example i mean partly because i
don't know enough about black culture
and
and and secondly i think it's like far
too various
um i went to uh public high school at a
time when integration was just
developing uh we had uh the only reason
we had integration in my high school was
because we were missing out on some
really good football players and so
finally like the football fans
uh there was like it was pretty big
overlap between the races and the
football fans but the football fandom
part of it won out over the racist part
of it and so we we began to have
but it wasn't like
i just did you know whereas appalachian
uh american culture is something that i
grew up with
there's a fair amount of it my own
family as a matter of fact
and and it was right down the street and
i know that and plus i went to school in
southern ohio and i know i know that's i
know the redneck side of things uh uh uh
pretty well in fact i you know have like
i say a little bit of redneck in me
myself so i wouldn't have used that
example
schools
why don't we face the school face up the
school problem why don't we try every
possible thing to make the school system
work why don't we try vouchers why don't
we really put our shoulder into uh
into charter schools and so i don't know
the answer to this it has to do i think
in part with the pretty bad political
culture that we have in most american
big cities i mean i am shame deeply
shamed by washington dc's public school
system and and
and i i i i know peggy k fritz a little
bit who was uh the head of the school
board here i've talked to people about
this uh uh i think this if this had an
easy solution it would have been fixed a
long time ago i know it's extremely
complicated i don't begin to understand
it
but i do you know
i i i there does not seem to be a will
in the united states to fix our our
public school system and it eludes me it
confuses me uh uh why that is not the
case
do you feel that wealthy people have a
moral spiritual or societal obligation
to assist those who aren't wealthy
daniel brown yes absolutely
it's a responsibility
absolutely an an important
responsibility it's a duty
it is not however a right
for people to get help
this is the key
difference
when you try to create when one tries to
create a free society
that free society has to be based upon
rights and those rights have to be what
are called negative rights
they are the right not to be coerced the
right
not to have stuff taken away from you
the right to free speech through they're
all the the important rights at the core
of a free society are nonzero some
rights
positive rights are another matter
positive rights are somebody's right to
something
from a society a right to food a right
to shelter a right to education
when you
start handing out those rights you are
per force
taking some things away from some people
and giving them to another
now all societies are going to do that a
bit
but i think it's much better to think of
those things as obligations and duties
rather than rights
otherwise you may be headed down the
leninist road
for the last three hours p.j o'rourke
has been our guest on in-depth this
afternoon here are the books enemies
list
the bachelor home companion
eat the rich
aging guy beat youth innocence and a bad
haircut
parliament of [ __ ]
the ceo of the sofa
give war a chance
holidays in hell
all the trouble in the world
modern manners
peace kills
and the most recent p.j o'rourke on the
wealth of nations
you can find all these on his website
pjork.com did you know you had a website
yeah but i've never looked at it
really seriously who maintains it
i assume the publisher
or possibly my nine-year-old daughter
one last tidbit this is seven days for
you without smoking
i am on seven days last smoking i was
i'm only slightly crazy today for the
previous six i have been nuts out of my
mind um yeah this is uh we'll see how
this goes but
you know
pushing the big 6-0 i can't uh i can't
keep this uh
stuff when i found myself inhaling
cigars big pig boat castro cigars i
thought
something's got to give here like you
said earlier you won a second act
yeah or at least the end of the first
one
pg or work thank you for your time very
well and thank you for spending part of
your sunday with us enjoy the rest of it
in depth with pj o'rourke re-airs
tonight at midnight eastern and next
saturday at 9 a.m eastern